[Applause]
we must
clap but I appreciate it Force claps but
small castles all about welcome ladies
and gentlemen SM Castle Cinemas I'm your
host Kevin
Smith so just a heads up uh we're not
starting yet we're about to start uh
this is just to say hi to everybody in
the room and whatnot when we start we'll
be live streaming the whole time and
whatnot um it's if
you
put
welcome my friends welcome to SM Castle
Cinemas I'm your host Kevin
Smith uh thank you for being here today
everybody uh here in the room uh anyone
watching online and whatnot this is the
Smokin now for folks who have not been
here before just uh some history what
this is about and whatnot because people
like I don't get it um we uh bought
bought a movie theater me and my friends
we thought it'd be so [__] fun and
easy this is the theater that we grew up
going to when we were kids and whatnot
um it was going out of business we were
like wanted to save we like [__] it
let's go in there and and it'll be just
like when we were kids like we the movie
theater will be packed all the time like
I've made money as a filmmaker now I'll
make money as a film exhibitor I'll get
both [__] ends it'll be amazing did
not work out that way at all uh we
bought a movie theater after covid so
film exhibition has been in the toilet
and I've used this examples many times
so folks in the audience will probably
be able to do it along with me or fill
in the blanks uh just to give you a a
case of of what exhibition looks like at
SM Castle Cinemas um Avatar 2 the way of
water and arguably one of the biggest
films of last year and the beginning of
this year or whatever the [__] or last
year um it did two billion bucks opening
night here at SM Castle Cinemas we had
12 people come watch it um opening night
of Creed Three also a huge hit kids how
many people were here
seven and one left so it's six total um
we did the nun two kids how many people
were here one one creepy poor
[__] was here watching that
movie by himself and [__] um so when we
do brand new movies and stuff we're
competing with other movie theaters and
also we're competing with the world
that's like I'll just stay home and
watch streaming I'll be able to watch it
in my house and like three weeks and
stuff um whenever we do events if we've
done like you know M rats with Jason Le
and Jeremy London Chasing Amy with Joey
Adams Tusk with Justin long and Genesis
Rodriguez um George RR Martin came the
Rouser Brothers came we could sell the
place out and upsell it and that helps
keep the lights on but the dayto day the
reality is it's tough to keep the lights
on and pay salaries so what we started
doing was at the events that I would
host we started doing auctions before
the screenings and they started small be
like 20 minutes half hour then we
started adding more and more because it
was is augmenting we were like oh [__]
we can pay salaries this week like
[__] Connor our manager can eat like
[__] so the auctions get longer and
longer and I'll never forget like there
was one auction that went for two hours
and at that point somebody in the
audience was like are we ever going to
watch the [__]
movie and after that some people were
like you should do it as its own event
we're like yeah we should and here we
are so we're here tonight uh to raise
money to keep the lights on here it's m
Castle Cinemas all the [__] proceeds
go to either getting me out here or
[__] uh paying our salaries or or
making the the electric bill and [__]
like that so uh thank you for your
support a bunch of people already jumped
online and bided uh thanks to Stephen
give it up for Stephen to the left right
there ladies and gentlemen Stephen is
our Cinema technician and he built the
entire smok em and Ernie organized it
last night meticulously upstairs and
whatnot went through every item um
inputting everything and whatnot it it's
taken a long time and an effort to do it
um so I thank them like I'm the guy
that's like o let's do a bunch of [__]
and they're like [__] how do we do it
they actually figure out how to put
those things together it's important to
be a dreamer don't get me wrong but it's
more important to be surrounded by
people that can Implement your dreams
because I'm I'm just a dreamer and
dreamers generally can't get [__] done
it helps to have people help you get
things done and in the case of Smokin it
don't exist without Stephen and and SM
Castle keeper Ernie OD Donald give it up
for him one more time
okay so it uh as we normally do it here
uh we'll be doing it the same way uh but
this time around we're adding an element
that's far more entertaining usually
it's just me up here barking and going
like I have 100 do I have 150 or
something like that we did an auction of
my artwork a few months ago um with
Bodner the auction folks and Joe Bodner
who was the AU auction caller was
nothing short of amazing I was so vastly
[__] entertained because he could do
that auction talk man you see on TV like
hey and I was like so I asked Ernie I
was like can we bring Joe and he was
like well I'll ask him and Joe said he
would [__] join us give it up for Joe
Bodner
[Applause]
everybody thank you sir um just give him
tell them give a bit of your credentials
Joe uh you come from the auction World
correct that is correct how long you
been doing it 30 years um what is the
auction game like is it fun or is it a
job it's everything to be honest with
you it's a ton of fun and it is a a
major job no matter how you look at it
going out and finding stuff it's like a
big treasure hunt you never know what
you're going to find it's a lot of fun
that way and then uh packaging it and
bringing it back there's a lot of
lifting and everything else so it's just
it's a lot of fun but a lot of work um
how is it on The Voice we did an auction
together not the TV show your actual
voice we did an auction together and
like it was four hours long at least
yeah we went four hours 5 hours I was
like what is this voice going to be like
the next day give him a taste of what
you do all right we're going to be going
one a quar 1 1 75 200 2 a qu 2 2 75 300
we'll be going like that so there you
have
it like I'm I'm not exaggerating I would
I would like I would I would rather
listen to that than [__] it's so
entertaining
well thank you so satisfying it's like
popping [__] like plastic bubbles
It's oddly satisfying one more time dude
yes 100 one and a quar one and a half F
now how'd you learn to do it give it up
for that that's amazing thank you how'
you learn to do it I taught myself
actually I yes I I started working for
an auction house when I was 17 carrying
Furniture to sad and uh one day he heard
me uh mimicking him downstairs and he
said oh we could put you up the
auctioner I said get out I'm not going
to do that so he gave me some exercises
of saying numbers back and forth upside
down and around and doing um different
chance such as Betty bner B some butter
but she said this butter bit if I put it
in my B my I buy bit better but put it
in bit B better better B put it in B
better better doing things like that but
what's slower back then the [__]
wouldn't want to get oral from you man
like look at that tongue it's
unbelievable so so well thank you sir
but as far as that's concerned um so
that was an offer by the way very I'm
hiding in playing sight I'm watching
your mouth going amazing there you go
but at any rate um so that turned into
auctioneering and then I ran my first
auction when I was 19 and then I've been
doing it ever since so now where can
they normally find you the folks at home
I auctioned with you where uh bodner's
auction.com you know we we're online pre
pandemic we're at the New Jersey
Convention Expo Center in Edison New
Jersey but uh it put us into uh the
online world and that's where I've been
this is my first and this is going to be
like my third live event really since Co
this third I've only done three Live
Events since Co serious yes everything's
been online prior to that we used to get
about 500 to 800 people sometimes a
thousand people we did a five ring
auction where we did all kinds of stuff
lots of toys Styles trains Collectibles
Comics pop culture everything uh but now
we just feature that online but I do a
live broadcast so you could actually
watch us on me or I'm bidding you're
bidding to the computer screen but we're
giv all this entertainment like we did
with your sale uh back in September I'm
telling you man like when you get bored
of Zillow and PornHub and you just want
to scroll through a thing [__] the
auctions are vastly entertaining you
lose time on a toilet watching this man
it's the highest compliment I can give
anybody um okay kids we have a bunch of
stuff to do and I can feel the seething
hatred from Smart Castle keeper Ernie
Odon who's like shut the [__] up and
start the auction because we have a lot
of items to get through um so Shall We
Begin let's do it man auction item
number one thank you
no we'll do that later let's start with
the yeah yeah we have some stuff that we
do for this crowd only for the people
who actually bothered to come out so
throughout the evening we'll be
sprinkling that in there but I don't
think we should begin with that let's
begin with what's up on the screen kids
what's up on the screen is a clerk 3
Jersey man uh right now the current high
bid is 200 this was made for me uh by
Daryl and uh he makes jerseys all the
time wonderful guy always been a
supporter of small castle and uh the
bidding is currently a is that correct
Stephen so I hand it over to Joe Joe you
do you think yes So the plan is we're
going to accept the high bid on the
internet and I'm going to look to the
audience and I'm going to try to
interact with you guys first if all guys
are out then we go back to the Internet
so that's basically the situation that's
the thought so I got 200 get 210 200 210
210 220 220 220 230 230 get about 240
240 get by 240 get about 240 sir 240 get
about 240 It's Only Money Now 240 240 I
know you're thinking about it who 40 get
by 40 get about 40 get by 40 I got 230
get by 240 230 get by 240 sir 240 240
get 240 get 240 get 240 get 230 get 240
235 help anybody he can't beat it for
five more bucks 235 235 get 235 get 235
235 thank you 240 240 get 45 45 now 50
50 get 50 get 50 50 get 50 get 5050
25050 $250 250 255 255 260 260 260 260
by 260 260 by 260 I got 255 260 now 5
265 265 now 70 70 now 5 75 75 75 75 yes
think you could think you should 75 now
80 80 80 8080 82 80 we're taking credit
card sir 280 who get my 280 who get my
280 I got 275 and 280 275 by 280 275 get
by 280 get by 20080 get by 280 I got
2 say that say it all right incorporate
that information 300 310 he's going to
sign the other Jersey 3 say it's super
fast he's going to sign the other Jersey
too so let's go 310 310 get 310 get 310
305 oh boy he's got a Jersey to H sign
too look at this 305 305 up by 305 305
yes 305 he's sign yeah 35 310 310 315
320 330 340 340 350 350 350 350 360 360
get by 370 370 get by 370 get by 37 you
started come on back now 370 I got 360
here been 370 by 370 3 get 370 get 370
get 360 get 370 get 370 360 B 370 370
get 370 get 370 get 360 B 370 370 380
380 380 380 I got 370 back there 380 390
back to you 390 390 get 390 get 390 get
390 get 390 get 390 385 help you I'll go
back to the $ recommit cuz that's what
we're set online 385 385 it's begging I
don't know 385 385 385 by 380 F by 385 I
got $380 with 385 what's the time limit
I got 37 seconds to go I got to beg for
another 3 35 seconds 385 I got 380 385
380 385 380 385 38 385 38 385 this is
like the countdown to New Year's Eve
watch a second I can't wait to come 20
seconds there you go 15 seconds 385 385
38 385 38 385 edging we are all edging
Joe bring us there 385 3 385 going once
3 385 going twice last
call and I stole it for
$380
congratulations right in the front
row
now we got to go way faster than that
otherwise we're getting through 10 items
so uh let's uh just just is an observer
so much it started the bit what was it
200 it began at we ended at 100 385 so
that was $185 worth of
talking yes give it up for my man
like thank you um but we should can we
do we have to wait until the timer goes
down or can we kill it at any
point you could do whatever you want all
right it's up to you though it depends
how much online bidding is going on but
that's up to you that's true um we with
some of them we'll just be like all
right let's let's move on yeah so we
don't spend like 10 minutes that's fine
by me done and done uh signing things
tag it up here meantime item number two
up for auction kids what do we got this
is the Jane Sal and Bob reboot location
and production design lookbook Ernie's
going to hold it up for you it's right
here this is what they gave us when we
did our location scout tour and it's got
uh not just the locations inside on maps
but also drawings of what the sets are
going to look like uh put together by
Nate our production designer uh
certainly not one of a kind but there
were only 10 made and I don't know where
the rest are most people throw [__] away
I save everything for Smokin um we are
currently at 350 350 yeah Jesus man
[__] I got to find some more [__] at
home hey um we at 350 I turn it over to
the mouth himself give it up for Joe
there you go 350 5 55 355 355 300 355
300 3 55 get about 355 get about 55 get
about 55 55 355 I got a $300 $350 bid
with 355 350 get about 355 55 get about
55 55 get 5 5 get about 5 5 get 55 55 55
55 55 55 get about 355 350 get about 355
get about 355 get about 355 this is a
one-of aind thing isn't it what do we
got
here I was trying to figure out my iPod
just before this is really really cool
come on guys now 350 get by 355 35 get
by 35 55 350 get about 355 I got one bid
online 350 bid 355 355 get about 355 get
about 355 anyone online can bid 355 you
can make me beg here too 350 get about
355 3 355 it's the best it's going to be
Joe I think so yeah 3 get by 355 going
once 355 get by 355 going twice last
call it says 1 minute 17 seconds should
we just last call it or should we wait
I'm about to come kill it all right
sold
$350 online
$350
online so so ladies and gentlemen if
you're watching online don't look at
that time countdown cuz uh there might
be a
pre-ejaculation ah Joe's getting with a
sexy program give it up for
[Applause]
Joe all
right next up kids we got an item from
lelu props lelu multi props Ashley who
is our co-owner Ashley and Joe have a
whole separate company uh where they do
prop they buy props for themselves but
they also do like autographs and stuff
that's how we met we did an autograph
signing with them and stuff so anytime
like you see they went to England
recently and did CLA for M rats and
whatnot so lelu multi props has a bunch
of stuff in the auction today one of the
first is this year uh movies lelu props
exclusive custom pop signed by Kevin
Smith Jason Muse Trevor Ferman Jeff
Anderson and Brian Ohan in so many
signatures such a little cow lot of Ink
on there take Joe 300 310 300 305 3 305
5 305 305 300 305 3 305 305 305 305 I
got a $300 bid online B
305 305 300 305 300 305 305 3 ain't
going to happen in this room man 300 305
3 30 5 anybody 300 by 305 going once 300
by 305 going twice last
call so for $300 online thank you all
for
bidding next
up item number four of 150 Jesus um is a
Clerk's VHS hockey Crest we have a
series of crests tonight kids uh the
ones that were made for my jersey so
this can go on any item of clothing that
you want me it across my chest and
whatnot uh we have a series of hockey
jersey crests they're all kind of
similar size and whatnot so we're going
to start rapid firing through them and
see if there's any interest Tak It Away
Joe all right I got 805 85 85 85 85 85
85 8 85 85 85 85 85
885 85 85 85 thank you now
90999 9985 999 90 90 5 95 95 95 95 95
100 100 100 100 100 100 think you could
think you should 100 bucks let's go 100
100 get 100 I got 95 here B 1005 get
about 100 I got 95 third row right in
the Hat bid 100 95 get 100 get 100 get
100 get 95 B 100 get 100 get 95 B 100 95
get 100 I'm going to look online real
quick see if we got 95 get 100 I got 120
yes thank you 120 now 125 well it went
up quickly over here 125 125 by5 125
down 30 130 130 130 125 get about 13 I
got 125 get about 130 get about 130 get
about 130 come on back now online 130
125 get about 130 12 get about 130 get
130 125 bid 130 125 get about 130 125
get about 130 going once is that a bid
online 125 yes I have 125 thank you but
125 get about 130 130 125 get about 130
going once 125 get by $130 going twice
last
call sold $125 nice byy sir right there
on the right thank you all for
bidding oh my God it's hypnotic to watch
uh next up number five is a movie hockey
Crest same idea kids but this one's
movie uh here we go Joe 160 online been
170 160 170 170 170 or 165 I should say
165 I got to get used to $5 increments
too 160 B
16560 165 5
5 165 I got a $60 bid 165 come on ladies
and gentlemen 165 165 165 16 165 160 165
160 165 5 165 165 going once 165 going
twice last
call sold $160 online thank you all for
bidding next up item number six is a
silent goalie hockey Crest man it's
Silent Bob as a hockey mask and once
again it goes on your chest these are
made of incredible quality uh just like
a New Jersey Devil's Crest or they're
cool yeah 120 125 120 125 125 125 125
125 125 125 125 I got 120 125 120 125
going once 120 125 going twice last
call sold
$120 online
online we're moving now
Ern he's happy I can see him he's got a
smile uh next up another hockey Crest
man this one is Gard State Parkway I
don't own it but I asked them to make it
and they put it on my black and white
Chicago style Jersey uh there you go man
uh starting at does it come with Easy
Pass
yes I got 120 125 120 125 120 125 125
120 125 125 125 125 I have 125 130 I
don't see it on here that's why I'm
asking 130 mine's not updating for
whatever reason 12 get about 130 120 get
about 130 120 get about 130 130 130 130
125 get by 130 125 get about 130 125 I'm
just looking up here I don't want to
lose it 125 get 130 get 130 get 125 bid
130 going once 125 of $130 going twice
last
call sold the $125 online I love when
you go rapid and then you stop and say a
normal sentence and then go right back
into rapid cuz you're
like exactly um okay next up another
hockey Crest uh this is me as the three
Funko Pops that I had been at the time
I've been many more Funko Pops since
then uh but these are the first three I
ever weree once again a hockey Crest and
we are at 80 bucks Take it Away Joe 805
85 85 85 now 990 909090 90 I got 85 in
the front row bid 90
909090 85 up here bid
909090 90 90 I got 85 here bid 90 85 90
85 90 90 now this is where in person
works much better I didn't realize how
big these were I looked at them before
to sale and I thought they were like
small little Pat these things are
fantastic that's what Ernie said to and
he was like why are you charging so much
for these well you couldn't you couldn't
even judge you couldn't scale it you
really couldn't scale it online these
are phenomenal put them next to a shark
or something so you can see uh we are
current 95 bit 100 95 get 100 100 get
110 100 B 105 rather 105 get about 105
105 105 105 105 105 I got 100 105 100
105 105 thank you 1 10 110 110 110 110 I
got 105 in the back right bid 110 It's
Only Money Now 110 sir 110 110 110 110
110 115 115 120 120 120 120 120 120
nothing to think about 120 120 120 120
120 I got 115 Yes 120 now 125 125 125
130 130 130 130 think you could think
you should 130 130 130 13 130 130 130
130 don't miss out now 130 120 about 130
I can see it it right across your chest
there 130 130 130 135 135 140 140 get
about 140 I don't want her have it now
140 140 140 145 145 145 you want in 145
145 150 150 155 155 155 155 so that's a
bid 155 155 she's already got her hand
on it 155 I need you to bid man 155 155
get about 155 get there's no friends
here 155 you're out you're out you want
to be 155
160 170 170 180 180 180 180 180 180 190
190 200 2 and a quarter 2 and a quarter
2 a qu two and a qu 2 and a quarter 200
get 225 200 get 225 get get by 225 going
once 200 get by $225 going twice last
call 225 250 250 275 275 275 27 5 275
275 275 2 275 going once 275 300 300 300
300 about 3 and a quarter 3 and a
quarter 325 325 about 325 I got 300
about 325 3 by 325 don't let have it now
325 3 by 325 going once 300 by
$325 going twice 325 350 350 350 375 37
375 350 375 350 375 don't thank God you
don't have guns in here 350 375 350 375
going once 3 by 375 going twice last
call you're
out sold
$350 on my right thank you both for
bidding thank you both for bidding
excellent
[Applause]
job Stu we
got and give it up for [__] Joe
[Applause]
[Music]
man uh we got another hockey Crest this
is the Widow Maker uh given to me or
designed for me uh by Eric Kosco one of
my friends who I worked on the Supergirl
shows with and stuff it was after I had
my Widow Maker heart attack and he got
me this Crest design and then I started
making it and selling it this is one of
the last ones we got left uh represents
one of the worst and best things that
ever happened to me uh coming up on six
years ago take it away 90 bit 100 9 100
100 95 90 bit 95 95 95 95 100
100 100 105 105 105 110 110 110 115 115
115 115 110 115 I got 110 in a back left
bid 115 110 bit 115 110 bit 115 get
about 1 15 get about 1 15 get about 1 15
get about 110 bit 115 110 bit 115 going
once 110 bit 115 $1 going twice I got
nothing online right last
call okay sold the $110 back left corner
back left
[Music]
corner next up I think we're out of
Crest world we are man there's a flash
ring that I wore for a while it opens up
and it has a tiny little suit sticker
inside really um I wore it while I was
making the flash I was gifted on the
flash and so I wore it all throughout
and what not cool and uh Grant Gustin
was like you know I've got the real one
I was like [__] you um but I did a war
what size I have no idea but it fit my
fingers it could be the right
size let's see I mean there's plenty of
room on my like on my chubbiest finger
um so I don't know I don't know ring
[Applause]
size but to show you it in action there
it opens up and there's a tiny suit
inside cool doesn't
work I got sign the Box take it away I
got 305 in 310 are you [__] me 3 31
310 310 310 3105 310 35 310 310 305 and
310 305 and 310 this is a very unique
piece just the story behind it is
phenomenal but I'm shocked it's going
for this much and this quick for
somebody realiz 31 by 310 going once 305
and $310 going twice last call and we
sold the $35 to the lucky person online
nice our next slot ladies and gentlemen
is this is unique as [__] man this has
been in my Personal Collection since
Malcolm Ingram stole it from rst video
years ago it's a copy of the movie
movers and shakers uh with Charles
groden and and a host of others came
from rst video itself um C70 means
comedy and it's the 70th movie that they
put into their system everyone was hand
numbered back in those days uh so if you
look very closely in clerch you'd
probably see it uh in the background of
one of the shots but it came from the
shelves of rst video 80 bit 90
technically screen used but you'd have
to look real hard to see but it was in
the background it was in the video story
were you kind and you rewinded or what
it is I don't even open it is it rewind
we got to charge somebody 50 cents 50
cents as well because it's not rewound
we'll take 50 cents off the purchase
price exactly 80 90
85 will I sign it absolutely 85 85 sir
in 85 B 90 9 get 9 get 90 get 90 get 90
get 90 get 90 get 90 get 90 get 95 95
get 95 100 100 100 100 105 105 110 110
120 13 130 140 140 140 150 150 150 160
160 160 160 160 170 170 170 170 came all
this way 170 170 170 180 do it again 180
180 180 180 180 180 180 170 180 180 17
180 170 180 180 175 175 175 now 180 180
180 180 180 now your turn 180 180 180
I'll take as a yes no I don't know 180
come on be 180 what's $5 more 180 180
18010 I got 175 here bid 180 175 180 175
180 175 180 going once anything online
175 bid 180 going twice last call you're
good sold
thank you sir right over
here okay next lot kids look at this
this is my uh Avengers uh Premiere pass
uh it's a uh from the premiere that was
in Los Angeles uh Hemsworth took me
Chris Hemsworth he had shot his Cameo
for Jane Silent Bob reboot that morning
and he had the premiere that day and he
asked me if I was going I was like they
don't invite me to that [__] and he's
like well I know a guy with a ticket and
I was like really who and he's like me
and I was like so I went as a guest of
Chris Hemsworth me and Harley she kept
her laminate uh it was here in in the
the upstairs apartment for a long time
and ear he was like what about this I
was like you know what there's probably
some fan out there that appreciate it
more than it hanging in my bathroom so
without yes lot of DNA on this
[__] 130 135 13 about 135 get
135 140 140 140 140 140 140 135 get
about 140 13 get about 40 get about 140
get about 135 get about 140 135 get
about 140 140 140 135 get about 140 135
get about 140 140 get above 145 145 150
150 150 155 155 55 55 160 160 160 160
160 150 160 160 he's saying yes how you
guys are talking about 160 160 160 now 5
165 165 165 now 170 170 170 170 170 170
170 170 170 170 170 170 165 bid 170
170 1 70 yes 170 behind me or not 170
170 170 165 in the front row here been
170 165 been 17070 170 165 170 170 170
170 165 in 170 going once 165 in
170 is that a bid is that a bid
online oh I got 165 here though we 170
170 170 170 170 you're 170 you're 165
don't worry I could take you again
though I'll gladly take some more money
out you 165 and 170 165 170 going once
165 and 170 going twice last call sold
$165
congratulations all
right the next Avengers premiere try to
use
it feel like I have this um okay next up
kids this is a screen used Captain
Marvel uh there's a scene in Jan S and
Bob reboot where um in Captain Marvel
the movie they referenced M rats so we
had Brody and Jane Silent Bob reboot
putting this on on the rack while he's
talking to uh Jaye salob at the
beginning of one of the shots little
shout out for the shout out that they
gave me uh it came originally from
showcase comic books and collectibles uh
out there in Louisiana because we shot
in uh New Orleans and uh screen used
handled by uh Jason Jason Lee the great
Jason Lee while he was playing Brody in
Jane salob reboot take it away all right
I got a thous wait what the [__] yes and
it's not even graded there you go I got
$1,000 B 1,005 ,000,000
5,000,000 5 to about 1,005 I got a
$1,000 bid B $1,000 five I know nobody's
beating that in this room thousand thous
nobody going B on this right you never
know
thousand I got ,000 online bit 1,005
about 1,005 about 1,005 about 1,005
going once don't miss out online there
is definitely a bidding war there they
still might be waiting thousand bit a
th5 going twice last
call
and sold $1,000 online there you
[Applause]
go I mean look all [__] auction
underwear come like who [__] knew
thousand bucks for a [__] comic book
uh kids Jane s and Bob get old uh poster
from a Filmore date that me and Muse did
uh April 10th 2018 the Filmore Detroit
lovely poster I think I signed it though
didn't I I did I signed it up there it's
not signed uh wonderful piece of artwork
I got one Fram to my house I had a spare
and it could be yours we're starting at
205 205 210 210 210 210 210 210 210 210
210 205 210 I got 205 online B 210 21 21
210 210 210 210 nothing to think about
210 205 get 210 205 bid 210 205 bid 210
going once 205 get by 210 going twice
let's call so for $25 online thank you
all for bidding
Lot Number 15 uh this was in uh Clerk's
3 uh deep in the background in uh
Randall's room whenever we're in
randle's apartment you could see it uh
it's created by Nate Gonzalez and its
artwork based on in M rats Brody went on
to do The Tonight Show this was an ad
that was in TV Guide at the time or
whatnot and since Randall and Brody are
cousins uh Randall had this hanging in
his apartment um so here it is 515 bid
520 520 520 520 thank you 520 525 525
525 525 525 525 yes 525 525 525 I got
$515 on my right bid
520 550 550 560 56 now it's 600 online
600 605 605 610 610 good to by 60 10 get
by 610 get by 610 get by 610 get by 610
610 get by
610 625 650 650 675 675 by 675 650 get
by 675 I got 650 here now bid 675 650 B
675 67
[Applause]
750 775 775 at 800 800 800 00 to 00 I
got 775 and 800 775 and 800 775 and 800
8 get 00 775 800 00 7 75 800 775 800 775
bid 800 going
once holy [__] 900 N9 and a
quarter 9950 29 50950 509 509 25 950 2
950 25950 29 509 509 25 bid 959 25 bid
950 going 1
wait wait wait okay oh wait wait wait I
got 925 bid 950 925 950 900 get 950 get
950 get 950 I got 925 950 there's
no I got a th000 thank you whoever has
that weird disposable income man you
just paid [__] Conor's salary for a
minute at SM Castle cus 1,50 1100 1100
1100 1100 1100 1,50 bit 1100 1,50 bit
1100 1,50 get 1100 1100 1100 1100 1,50
bit 1100 1,50 1100 1,50 bit 1100 any
more online or no 1,50 bit 1100 1100
going once 1,50 bid $1,100 going twice
last
call and we sold it for
$1,050 online thank you for bidding in
house we appreciate that many thanks for
bidding in house many thanks for bidding
online and thank you for supporting smog
Castle Cinemas next up kids uh we've got
a reboot Road show uh poster from Grand
Rapids Michigan uh from the stop of the
Jane Silent Bob reboot Road Show tour uh
inexplicably Adam West Batman is
featured in it which I always found very
Charming uh the iconography they chose
to include including the pay phone from
Quick Stop just baffles me man but uh
it's dated and I've got one framed in my
house go ahead cool H one a quarter 125
125 get about 150 125 get50 get 150 150
get50 125 and 150 125 get about 150 125
get about 135 125 get about 135 135 125
135 125 135 125 get about 135 get about
145 140 45 145 145 get about 145 I know
you're thinking about it I got 135 in
the back right bid 145 135 get about 145
135 get about 140 140 140 145 145 145
150 150 150 150 150 150 get 150 get 150
get 150 150 150 150 150 150 160 170
you're all out now 170 170 170 I got 160
to the internet been 170 170 170 170 160
170 170 160 170 160 170 170 160 17 170
165 help anybody 165 yes 170 170 170 170
170 170 I got 165 on my left been 170
170 170 165 been 170 165 170 65 170 165
bid 170 going once 165 bid 170 going
twice last call we're good sold the
$165 here on my left thank you all for
bidding thank you thank you sir Rock
neighbor neighbor's a longtime supporter
man uh okay number 17 Jesus uh Buddy
Christ sweatshirt um you know it's a not
a sweater it's actually like a
sweatshirt sweatshirt material and stuff
and um it celebrates the holiday with
everyone's favorite nonfictional
character uh two XL right here kids so
it's warm and snugly for almost
anybody for what you're already B you're
in all right he said 200 I'll take it
200 225 200 225 225 200 225 225 I got
200 225 200 2 25 I got 205 210
215 15 15 15 215 25 215 215 215 215 250
250 250 250 250 250 25 I got $210 here
on my left at 215 I need you on the
internet at 25 250 1550 get 15 get 250
get 250 get 250 get 250 get 210 215
going once 210 get 250 yes 215 or's a
yes yes 25 220 thank you 220 225 22 225
220 by 225 22 225 225 225 220 by 225 220
225 going once I got 220 here on the
second R but 225 going twice last call
we're good so $22 right here backto back
winner Joe just a little inside baseball
I noticed you don't use the gav like a
judge no I guess not like this you mean
yeah yeah with the stick I was always
taught not to point it at people it's
rude you got to go like this I swear to
God that's what they tell you you got to
go like this they're not scissors it's a
gabble no I guess not I guess it's a g
um all right next item we got up kids
number 18 this is a Young Frankenstein
print signed by Mel Brooks this comes
from the good Folks at lelu multiprops
um Mel Brooks
signed Young Frankenstein poster uh rare
as [__] how many how many things I have
nothing signed by Mel Brooks um here's
your chance I could bid that's
right but I also know the people who
sell it so maybe I can make a deal later
on we're starting the bidding go ahead
Jo 500 510 5 5 T 505 rather there
555 5005 55
555 500 bid bid
5055 55 500 55 500 55 500 55 going once
looking online now I got 500 started B
505 I'm about 505 going twice SL
call sold for $500 on the internet thank
you Le
multiprops the next Lot number 19 we
have a Clerk's signed photo with an
additional signed uh Clerk's trading
card that was signed by the late great
Lisa spoon hour so you have uh Kevin
Brian Jeff and Marilyn signed on one and
then included is Lisa's signature on the
card she did the card set with us before
she sadly passed away a few years ago we
missed her right up until this moment
and Beyond um take it away 275 but 280
285 I got your 280 online but 285 85 285
285 290 I see it 295 295 295 by 295 now
300 295 and 300 295 300 300 300 300 got
295 and 300 295 by 300 3 by 3 290 V by
300 I got 295 online been 300 2905 by
300 300 by 300 310 I see it now 310 315
ret by 315 ret by 315 ret by 35 350 by
315 hey T 315 350 35 I need a swivel
chair so I got swivel back and forth T
350 350 350 3 T 350 by 3 T by 315 going
once ah thank you 320 now five 320 20 25
320 25 25 2 25 30 I got 330 now 335 33
335 well it's updated on my screen it
says 3:30 is that correct just making
sure 33 yes 3:30 online ni 3:35 33 335
33 335 get 330 335 get 330 get 335 going
once 330 but
$335 going twice last call we're good
sold $330
online we thank our good friends at lelu
multi props for donating that lot kids
we're finally at lot number 20 of
150 um this is the Jay and Salon Bob ma
brawl game um from the folks in inter
gang and a spooky uh spooky Bard
production spoon board spoon Bo
Productions um this was the you could
buy the game online and play it they
made a version that looks like an actual
Super Nintendo cartridge that you could
play um Do's a
play it plays in a
Nintendo do we know what color the
Game Boy which fact this doesn't have
any of the Little rings on it so I'm not
so I don't know what color it represents
so it plays on an NES system yeah this
is cool it's a Nintendo game wow um and
it was like kind of the game that they
put out uh while they're still building
um the other game the uh chain Bob this
ma braw is more scrolling game if I
remember correctly this is neat Guys One
of a Kind 200 two and a quarter and it's
signed by Yours Truly 200 225 225 200
225 200 by 210 200 210 210 210 get by
205 205 get about 205 200 205 two excuse
me 200 by 205 205 2 205 2 205 200 205
200 20 5 going once 200 get by $25 going
twice I think that's cheap guys I'd put
it in my collection can be cheap 200
about 205 going twice last call sold for
$200 online $200
online we got you that swivel chair
thank
youh okay next up kids item number
21 the grass to give it up for
Conor he makes things happen here at SM
uh de grassy the movie script uh draft
1.5 dated uh June 13 2005 at one point I
was going to direct a whole last a
grassy movie for theaters and stuff um
and then the thing W I wound up doing
something else and they turned it into
three or four episodes of the program
and Jason was involved he played the
director and stuff and I popped up in
the episodes but it was actually meant
to be a feature at the end of which
Jimmy would get up and walk and [__]
very inspiring um so so here's your
script kids take it away 105 110 110 110
110 110 105 110 110 get about 110 110
110 110 105 11 115 1 15 1 15 15 15 150 1
15 1 15 1 15 get 110 115 110 11 15 11 15
110 get50 15 150 115 I got 110 in the
front row bid 115 150 150 1 15 110 bid
115 110 bid 115 going once online uh we
have 110 here bid 115
110 bit 11 15 get about 110 15 I got 110
here bit 115 get about 115 going once
110 bid $15 now 115 thank you or 120 now
125 125 now 130 130 130 130 130 125 130
130 130 it got me off those 15 numbers I
don't like that 15 130 121 get 130 130
130 130 125 get 130 130 get 13 130 130 I
got 125 here been 130 get about 13 get
about 130 going once 125 into the
audience here bid 130 going twice last
call sold $125 right here by
her right there so gratifying excellent
job my friend take a Brea or take a
drink uh kids number 22 is Comic Book
Men poster signed by uh Yours Truly this
was to advertise I want to say season
three if I remember correctly to be fair
there is a tear under my uh signature
but I wrote I love you on top of it just
in case uh Ernie will hold up for you so
you can see the whole thing and
currently it's at 280 bucks wow 280 285
285 85 85 85 85 85 285 285 280 285 280
285 285 280 285 get by 285 280 get by
285 280 get by 285 get by 280 by 285 get
by 280 get by 285 going once comic book
F guys 280 get by 285 going twice last
call
sold $280 on the internet 280 on the
internet mov right along kids the next
lot lot number 23 is a p a deck of
clerk's three cards uh th this was
puzzling to so many people so much so
that they took them out of uh commission
uh the good Folks at zerocool made these
uh pack of cards and they look they're
meant to look like one hitter boxes so
if you're a stoner who uses a one hitter
box you know what this is to the rest of
the world they're like I don't get it
why is it a brown box what's inside
nobody opened it because it was sealed
inside there's this deck of uh Clerk's
trading cards like AER were openen
Clerk's 3 uh rst THC really nice deck of
cards but poorly sadly put together and
so they changed it and then reissued
them all together so this one's up for
grabs it's rare if that's the case no
current bid yeah but oh [__] we
sawell this in the stash moving on all
right uh next item is um oh the INF The
Avengers Infinity War signed poster uh
we had the Russo Brothers here two
months ago and they did a lovely Q&A up
here on stage uh they were gracious
enough to sign a bunch of posters
knowing that we were going to auction
them off for the theater and stuff this
is one of them right here so you got an
Infinity War poster signed by the two
directors of infinity War take it away
250 bid 55 255 get about 55 get 55 55 55
55 250 get by 255 250 get by 255 250 get
255 get by 255 get 250 get by 255 250
get by 255 250 get 255 get 55 get 250
get 255 get 250 get 255 250 get by 255
going once on that poster guys 250 get
by 255 going twice SL
call sold
$250
online uh number 25 we've got a sign
Chasing Amy post poster it's signed by
Joey Adams who came here to show the
movie and it's signed by me my signature
is not depicted on the image but it's on
the poster I did it earlier today two
people involved in Chasing Amy and one
of them is on the actual poster take I
got 3:25 and 330 325 about 30 30 30 30
325 get 330 get 325 get 330 325 330 get
330 get 330 325 get 330 325 330 32 get
330 get 330 get 330 325 get 330 32 330
get 330 get 330 32
bid 330 330 330 325 bid 330 going
once2 by 330 going twice last
call sold
$325 online online
brilliant
absolutely uh next
up we've
got Supergirl t-shirt kids uh this was
from season 2 episode 9 uh whenever I
wrapped to one of the CW shows I made a
t-shirt like on movies you make a rap
shirt as a gift give it out I did the
same thing uh I sign in the back on on
the back it says I went to outer space
with Kevin Smith and Supergirl it's uh a
rendition of uh the uh crisis in
infinite Earth's cover famous cover
where Superman is holding a dead
Supergirl instead Silent Bob is holding
a dead Supergirl and wailing his heart
out uh right now no current bid [__] all
right we try it we're trying it yeah
$100 hour1 about
75 75 now I'm going in reverse ladies
and gentlemen pay attention
$50 we only go in reverse once in a
while 50 50 50 50 50 50 60 60
sir had him at 5501 SP
60 60 I have $50 to the gentleman in the
half bid
60 60 going once 60 thank you now 70 770
70 8080 8080 80 80 70 now 80 80 80 9090
9090 now we got an auction 9090 9090 now
we're going the right way 90 9090 9090
95 more dollars sir
90 yes 90985 990 85 990 8590 going once
85 $90 going twice last call sold $85
hour in the Hat back there thank you
both for bidding thank you both for
bidding Lot Number 27 is uh Diamond Jay
and Silent Bob merchandise design binder
open this up for him this is a bunch of
toys that we did with diamond and
they're the breakdowns and designs and
all different angles of what the figures
uh look like so it's not just the blunt
man and chronic figures but it's also
keep flipping um each section has
something so like the movie bank is in
there as well um lots of designs of
merchandise that we did with diamond a
rare collectible there's uh [__] knocker
this is for the Migo dolls we had done
the Migo style dolls so yeah it's crazy
rare it's got blunt blunt Sabers in it
and everything like production it's
production stuff it is it's how we got
to the actual dolls that we made very
cool 200 205
200 2 205 205 one of a kind stuff God
you don't find this stuff every
200 205 200 get 205 get 205 get 205 I
would assume it's one of a kind correct
I don't think there's anything else
maybe a second I think it was sent to me
and that's it maybe they got one in
their corporate exactly that's what I'm
saying one of a kind ladies gentlemen
200 205 200 25 205 200 205 200 205 200
205 200 205 going once 200 get by $25
going twice last
call sold for $200 on the internet $200
on the
internet um all right kids next up we've
got clip all right a big clip for yall
uh it's a hockey Crest uh of the uh [__]
uh Crest from Jay and S Bob Strike Back
the the uh uh what is it Coalition uh
for the liberation of itinerate it's a
it's a nice big [__] yes huge [__] there
you go get your hands on it kid if you
can find it exactly 115 mid 120 15 120
120 about $115 for the quit bid 120 oh I
got 12050 get about 12050 get about 120
about 120 about 12 15 mid 120 1 15 120
120 12 15 120 going once no no say [__]
a few more times I they say Quint is
worth more money than that come on now
120 get about 120 get about 120 on the
quit
120 quit 12 12 15 120 120 120 12 120 on
the quit last's
call going once going
twice sold sold the quit to the internet
excellent job give it for Joe that's
phenomenal I've never heard [__] so fast
in my life uh next up is another crest
mon rille zombies no current bid let's
move
on um next up is a tus cocky crust
current high bid is 90 uh this was a
silent Tusk if you will so it's Tusk
with a Silent Bob backwards baseball cap
proudly uh displayed across my chest
95555 95 9 95 90 b95 90
b95 95 95 get five get 90 get five 90
bid get a 90 bid get a 90 bid five going
once I got a $90 bid bid $95 going twice
last
call sold for $90 or 95 I got 95 yes uh
next up we got there was 95 sold there
you go recap it yes well done all right
next slot uh number 31 is Moose Jaws
hockey crest for the movie that I am
desperately trying to make get done this
year uh that's my my end of the year I
think is going to be moose Jaws I
already told all my reps and stuff this
is the year we make moose jaws and they
were like why and I was like because
it's like you know how only Nixon can go
to China only Kevin Smith can make moose
jaws and like I have to do it and they
were like we get it and so we'll be
heading toward that by the end of the
year in meantime this is the crest that
I used to wore across my chest uh of
moose jaws and we're currently at 100
ticket away Jo I got 100 105 100 105 105
110 120 120 120 120 120 get about 120
get 120 get about 120 120 you're my 110
120 130 now back to you for 130 sir 130
140 140 150 150 160 160 170 180 180 190
190 190 190 now 200 2 and a quarter 2
and A2 2 and A2 275 275 275 he came all
this way 275 275 don't one them have it
now 275 now 300 300 3 and a quarter 325
325 by 325 It's Only Money Now 325 300
by 325 300 by 325 about 300 by 3 25
going once 300 by
$325 going twice last
call so for $300 right there thank you
both for bidding thank you both for
bidding thank you folks for your support
of SM Castle cinnamon next up Lot number
32 is a j and Tom Bob hockey crestes no
current bid so let's move on what's the
next
one uh this is a uh jeno and Kevin Smith
collab shirt uh I was doing jeans with
jeno in an incarnation of jeno that them
went out of business so we didn't wind
up doing it jeno's been reopened twice
since then by different companies and
stuff so I have a set of [__]
prototype jean shorts with my face on
the
ass the shirt
[Music]
is red says it's large man uh so it's
one of the this doesn't ex exist any
place they sent it to me as the Proto as
like this is going to be our logo and I
said fantastic uh but it never wound up
happening so it's for collab that didn't
turn out to be I got 45 bid 50 4 get
about 50 60 70 70 80 80 8080 8080 80 70
8080 75 help you 75 75 now 80 80 8080 85
885 85 85 85 80 out there bid five 85
get 85 85 get 85 85 get 90 90 get 90
five 95 95 95 95 95 9 95 95 95 think you
could think you should 95 95 thank you
95 1001 105 105 105 105 105 105 105 105
105 105
10555 110 get 115 115 115 115 get about
150 get 1 15 1 15 1 15 get 110 get 115
It's Only Money Now 115 now 120 120 125
125 get 125 125 get 125 now 130 130 130
13 135 get about 135 either one of you
now 1 135 135 130 get about 135 13 get
about 135 get about 130 get about 135
get about 130 get about 135 go going
once $13 about $135 going twice they're
talking about it one more time last call
sold the $130 in the back right
done thank you both forbidding all
forbidding yeah incredible um okay
number 34 is the yoga hoser chairback uh
when you make movies you do chairbacks
everybody says the director's chairs
this one is the Director of Photography
this is James laxton's chairback and
stuff and shows you how much he cared
about yoga hosers we had multiples uh
here you go so is the DP man uh the dp's
chair back from the movie uh Yogo take
it away 195 bit 2005 get bu 200 get bu
get get get 200 get bu one of a kind as
well guys you can't get these online 200
except for right this moment 200 200 get
200 I get 200 I get get 200 get 200 205
I got a 205 bid 210 205 online bid 210
205 210 210 210 205 210 205 210 210 get
by 210 get 210 get 2 105 and 210 205 and
210 going once 210 I got a 215 210 get
15 15 15 now 20 220 220 220 220 25 now
220 250 220 220 about 5 2205 225 225 220
225 220 225 220 225 going once 220 get
by
$225 going twice last call
sold $220 buyer number
internet Lot number 35 my friends this
is the four mentioned jeno shorts I was
talking about look it says Kevin Smith
up top on the back it's my Silent Bob
Hawk face um prototype size 42 by 13 and
it's got the Jingo and Kevin Smith
collab patch right
there truly [__] rare man uh and
there it is you could probably fit 19
people into it um starting at what 205
Take it Away Joe 205 AT 210 205 by 210
210 210 210 215 210 15 take to 15 take
15 take 25 215 25 25 250 250 215 I got
210 bid 215 210 get 250 get by 215 I got
it now 220 220 220 22555 get by 25 220
get by 225 I got 220 back there b 225 on
the internet 225 225 225 I got 220 in
the back here been 225 225 225 220 225
200 225 225 225 by 220 5 get by 220 get
by 225 now 230 230 230 230 230 235 5 get
by 35 235 get 5 5 get 35 235 get 35 get
35 get 30 get 35 get about 35 get 35 get
about 35 get 303 get about 35 going once
23 get by $235 going twice last call
we're good
right I got 230 back there 2 you got 235
235 I got 230 back there 235 240
250 250 250 250 250 250 250 I got 240
but 245 now 250 I see it 260 260 270 270
270 270 270 270 270 or 265 rather 265 by
265 265 I got 26 in the back bit 265 26
by 265 26 by 265 get by 265 going once I
got 260 in the back of the building with
265 going twice last call I'm good sold
$260 in the back right thank you both
for
[Applause]
bidding um okay uh Lot number 36 we got
the Avengers uh endgame sign poster
again signed by the Russo brothers when
they came to speak at SM Castle back in
November they're very gracious about
signing some [__] for us take it away
Joe I got 200 bid 205 200 25 205 215 25
215 215 25 215 25 get 215 get 25 get 210
get 215 21 25 21 get 25 get 250 get 250
get 215 250 get 215 I got $210 here been
215 210 get by 215 210 get by 215 get
210 get 25 get 210 get by 215 going once
$210 here B
$215 going twice last
call sold $210 right over here thank you
all for bidding give it up for him for
supporting SM Castle Cinema
kids uh if you're at home and you just
tuned in you're like what the [__]
going on uh we're doing an auction a
live auction ladies and gentlemen and
even if you're not bidding on anything
it's so worth it to watch the amazing
pipes of Joe Bodner give it up for Joe
everybody thank you
silky all right what uh we are going to
number 37 a Marvel Studio signed box set
of phase 2 movies that is Iron Man 3
Thor of the Dark World Captain America
Winter Soldier Guardians of the Galaxy
Avengers Age of Ultron and Ant-Man um
it's got that British 12 so I think it's
from overseas but it plays on any DVD or
Blu-ray player and uh it's signed by the
Russo Brothers current High bit 125
ticket away 125 130 130 130 130 130 1225
get above 130 get above 130 get above
130 get 12 get 13 13 13 13 13 13 131 12
13 13 12 13 12 13 13 13 132 130 12 130
going once $1 12205 about $130 going
twice last
call sold $125 online
[Music]
online Lot number 38 kids uh is the
phase three box set signed by the Russo
brothers so it has Captain America Civil
War Doctor Strange guard Galaxy Volume 2
Spider-Man homecoming and Thor Ragnarok
100it 105 100it 105 105 105 1055 105 100
bit 105 100 bit 105 105 105 105 105 105
105 105 105 100 bit 105 100 bit 105 105
105 100 bit 105 100 bid 105 100 bid 105
going once I got a $100 bid here bid 105
going twice last
call sold $100 hour online $100
online
uh and we got one more uh phase phase
well was all far of phase three this is
part two of a box set that has black
panther Avengers Infinity War Ant-Man in
the WASP Captain Marvel Avengers endgame
and Spider-Man far from home once again
signed by uh the Russo Brothers 150 155
155 get about 155 get about 55 55 55 55
150 get about 155 150 155 150 155 155
get 150 155 going once
15 $155 going twice last call sold $150
online
online Lot number 40 is this Chasing Amy
poster prototype this is what they
handed to me this and three others see
there's a number one on it there were
two other posters that they were like
these are the image images that we think
the poster is in late like
1996 and so I was like clearly this is
the one which really upset Affleck
because he was like oh the movie's all
about her her you know how come I'm not
on the poster I was like they did have a
poster with you on it and he was like
did they I said yeah but it was the back
of your headit um and they used that for
the home video was CR so this is the one
I chose and then it became the poster
for Chasing Amy so this is the Proto
that they handed me that got the poster
approved and and the journey began 350
355 get about 355 get by 355 this is
also oneof a kind piece right there is
one of a kind 53 55 5 55 55 55 55 55 55
55 555 355 get by 355 3 get by 355 300
get by 355 going once 350 B
$355 going twice last
call sold $350 online online online
stranger uh along the lines more of like
emptying the drawers and [__] this is a
Green Hornet marketing book from 2003
for when I was working on the film this
is the thing that made me step away from
Green Green Hornet they had me meet with
people about toys they had me meet with
the Air Force about using a hornet Jet
and I hadn't even written a word of the
script and so they handed me this book
with the designs of all the characters
and the toys and I was like so do you
need me at all you just want me to sit
here and cuck it out and [__] like that
so I've held on to it forever this is a
look at like the Green Hornet movie kind
of that I was going to make but again
they made all these designs Without Me
based on the idea of the title alone huh
interesting 105 110 105 110 110 110 1105
1105 110 105 11 110 110 110 110 110 110
110 100 1105 110 going once5 $110 going
twice last call do we have it oh we have
a big jump 130 135 13 about 135 get
about 135 about 135 13 about 135 13 get
about 135 get about 5 5 get 130 get 13 5
get 130 get 135 get 13 get 135 going
once 13 to 135 going twice last
call sold $130 online
online uh Lot number 42 my friends is
got no current bid so we're g we're
moving
on well it's Jersey but there's no bids
on it and the starting is like 500 and
[__] it is it's beautiful but put it
away okay next up holy [__] little piece
of History right here this is one of the
strikes uh signs that I used to go
strike outside of universal when we had
the strike a few months back me and Mark
Bernard and so you know they give you a
blank uh placard to strike with and so
that's what I came up with without
writers Hollywood is Silent Bob and um I
thought my mother thought it was clever
and
um uh that's uh what I was out on the
picket lines with so that's a little
piece of History right there you know
right here that's history should be
should be a Smithsonian really me and
Mark single-handedly changed the writer
Guild there you go by standing out there
205 210 205 get 210 210 get 210 get 210
215 215 25 25 210 get 25 get 250 get 250
get 250 get 250 250 get 220 220 get 220
get 225 225 225 230 230 230 230 it's
really a part of history and you're
never going to see something like this
again 230 235 2305 by 2305 23 250 260
260 down 260 260 260 50 by 260 250 by
260 I got $250 bid bid 260 250 260 260
by 260 270 270 280 280 280 280 290 290
290 290 290 300 300 about 310 310 310
310 310 you're never going to see
another one 310 320 320 320 very unique
piece 320 320 320 about 320 320 330 330
330 330 I think we had a problem with
the current
bid 330 330 get in there and you can
resell it for that much 330 look look at
the bid online I know you saw honor the
$275,000 bid
Joe am I taking that
bid just close it sell it in room might
as well close it and sell it in the room
yeah my idea it's a little hard to
believe but you never know I don't know
this could be somebody out there going
like I'm serious I have a quarter of a
million dollars exactly I want to save
the theater we like [__] moving
on
330 if you are truly a real billionaire
and [__] like that please let yourself
be known more than a random bid that
looks fake 330 330 get about 330 330 340
340 340 350 3 3 V 3 V 3 V three this
could be like hitting the lottery
because that person could be real and it
could be really pissed off and you could
sell it to him for that price wait What
yeah I'm just saying 350 why be 350 50
by 350 yes 350 360 3 3 3 by 360 I got
30050 by 360 3 by 360 3 by 36 by $360
going once 350 by
$360,000 going
twice sold $350 thank you all for
bidding there you
go done and done uh next up we got the
other uh Writers Guild strike sign I
used outside the Warner Brothers lot uh
and this was outside the flash poster
which said world's collide Som thing
said Worlds Collide only after words
Collide now we're trending a million
dollars right oh
[__] 200 a much more affordable uh $200
there you go 200 get 210 200 get 210 210
get by 210 210 get 210 get 210 get 210
220 220 get 220 get 220 get 220 get 220
get 220 get by 220 get by 220 220 230
230 get by 230 230 240 240 240 240 250
250 get by 260 260 260 260 270 270 270
280 280 280 280 300 310 320 320 by 320
320 by 3 this is the last one guys 320
320 by 320 right this is the last one I
think we're selling today 320 320 by 320
by 320 320 320 320 get 320 get 320 get
320 I got $310 with 320 31 by 320 31 by
320 320 31 by 320 going
once 310 B 3 oh 350 360 360 get by 360
370 370 get by 370 by 370 I got 360 B
370 360 get by 370 360 by 370 get by 370
I got 360 way in the back with 370 you
out 370 370 370 360 B 370 3 by 365 3 by
365 going once 360 B
$365 going twice last
call sold
$360 way in the back excellent job thank
you for supporting SP Castle Cinemas uh
folks uh just for a little uh uh texture
for the folks at home uh while we're
doing this uh we are also shooting a
Sizzle reel today uh for a proposed
reality show set at SM Castle Cinema so
sometimes you'll see like cameras
running in and out in stuff um we're
getting many things done today while
we're doing this and then of course we
have the Zach andir screening at night
so uh if you see people at home because
we talked to the crew here before we
went online if you see folks uh running
in with cameras that's to explain it I
just saw a text from somebody going why
are people running around the cameras I
was like we're trying to make another TV
show um okay we are
at
45 lot 45 right but Lot number 45 is a a
psych uh for the TV show Psych 3D screen
print signed by the entire cast flip it
around red it's got 3D glasses on it so
you can put it on look at the poster and
get trippy and [__] and it's signed by
the entire cast um donated by the good
Folks at lelu multiprops give it up for
him we are at 400 Take it Away Joe I got
400 been 405 400 405 45 405 400 405 400
405 400 45 about 45 about 400 about 45
about 400 about 45 about 400 about 405
going once 400 about 45 going twice last
call did we go up 405 410 405 get about
410 get about 410 get 405 get about 410
405 get about 410 410 get about 410 get
about 410 about 405 about 410 405 get
about 4010 going once 405 about $410
going twice last
call sold $45 hours online
online uh next up also from the good
folks lelu multiprops a Mall Rats uh
cast sign poster looks like the cover of
the old uh uh laser disc nvhs the cast
signing it can I Jason let me see you
got Jason Lee Claire fani Jeremy London
Shannon dty Renee Humphrey Ethan SLE and
you know I could sign it to
too I was in this movie Once uh and so
we'll add a Silent Bob as well a Kevin
Smith bidding is at Jesus 550 [__] 550
555 550 Claire is rare everyone else
like you know Jeremy Jason Lee me we go
to cons and stuff even Shannon you've
seen it a con or two but uh Claire has
never been anywhere so she's like the
rarest signature of the bunch I think as
a Kevin Smith fan I was very excited by
the CLA thing
but as a huge Kevin Smith van I'm way
more excited than he signed it too there
you
go I know I ruined it didn't I like 50
bucks 560 been 565 570 575 575 575 575
now 600 75 by 600 75 by 600 600 600 600
5 75 by 600 I got 580 590 590 get 590
get 590 get 590 now 600 I got 590 bid
600 590 600 600 600 600 590 6 6 590 600
I got 590 here B 600 59 get 600 590 get
600 59 get 600 600 thank you 610 610 get
610 get 610 I got 600 610 6 61 6 61 61 6
61 6 61 going once 600 going to BU $610
605 I see now 610 605 B 610 6 605 get
610 605 610 get 610 605 610 605 get 620
625 620 get 625 62 62 625 6 625 6 625 6
625 going once 620 with $625 going twice
last call sold
$620 buyer number uh internet thank you
internet for your sport of SM House of
Cinemas but give it up for the [__]
voice ladies and gentlemen Joe Bodner
the most tireless tongue in this
building and [__] you're the last thing
we're going to auction off a night with
Joe Bodner I don't know man my wife
would not like that but fair enough we
we we'll split the profits there you go
uh okay next up we have lot 47 inom Man
cast signed custom whee print the weasel
inom Man cast signing it is Brendan
Frasier Shan Aston and Paulie
Shore 400 405 400 405 get 405 405 400
405 4 405 400 405 45 about 400 about 420
I see now 425 420 about 425 420 about
425 420 about 425 4 20 4 25 4 25 4 25 42
4 25 4 25 about 4 25 about 4 about 4 25
going once 420 bid 4 $25 going twice
last
call sold $420
online thank you to whoever bought it
thank you to the good Folks at lelu
multiprops for donating that as well
next
up20 I know [__] that 420 number was
perfect then somebody was like I hate
jokes um here we go kids the next lot
lot number 48 is a signed Clerk's two
poster and it is signed by uh who's on
it
yeah Kevin Smith J Muse signed by me
signed by Jay signed by Brian and signed
by uh Jeff so you got four four Dudes
have been in every [__] clerks thing
there's ever been um and they've all
signed this Clerk's 2 poster I got 375
now been 380 he somebody 380 380 380 385
385 385 380 F 380 F 385 I got 380 down
here but 385 38 385 38 385 385 3 90 390
390 390 now 400 390 about 400 390 about
400 390 about 400 about 400 about 400
about 400 about 390 get by 400 390 get
by 400 390 get by 400 get by 395 help
anybody 390 get by 395 390 get by 395
400 400 hold on 400 here bit 410 405 410
420 420 the magic number 420 420 about
420 about 420 420 now 430 430 43 about
40 30 get about 4 30 about 4 30 get
about 4 30 get about 425 425 425 about
425 42 about 425 get about 42 get about
4 25 get about 42 get about 4 25 going
nobody wants to ruin The Joke Man
everyone wants to hit that
420 430 430 then we might as well go for
the next magic 435 469 that's what we
want all right we're all 469 430 uh what
do we got we got 450 we're getting
closer to the 69 450 455 perfect about
455 about 455 4 455 4 455 about 455 4
you came all this way 455 sir we're
getting closer to 69 you might get in
there 4 about 455 4 about 455 about 455
455 460 4 60 4 60 4 60 40 40 40 40 46
460 460 460 about 460 455 and 460 455 4
70 minus one hey yeah we're past the
magic number we're done we finished 74
74 70 4 74 70 4 75 7 4 75 7 4 75 4 7 4
75 4 7 4 75 going once horse tr to get
about
$475 going twice last
call and I sold it for
$470 excellent job on the internet thank
you thank you so much internet kids here
in the audience you're having a good
time so
far cuz there's so much to go uh Lot
number 49 is a signed of fat man Funko
Pop I wrote Kevin Smith on the front
window and I wrote I Heart You current
bid is 200 take it away 200 get by 205
200 205 205 20 2005 200 205 200 205 200
205 205 200 get 205 going once 200
$25 going twice last
call sold $200 on the internet
$200 we're finally there kids lot 50 man
this is officially the halfway mark of
where Ernie was thinking we will not get
so how long have we been doing this
since 2 o'clock it's now 12:38 but
that's West Coast time listen this is
like a this is like a casino you don't
give them the hours that's true man just
pumping o there's no no windows no C no
time that's right it's Timeless here
kids M got c um okay next up item number
50 is a clerks 3 signed screenplay we
gave these away if you were a VIP member
of the clerk's convenience tour signed
by Jeff Anderson uh Brian o' Haller and
Kevin Smith Jason Muse Marilyn gigliotti
and blockchain himself Austin zier so
there's a host of signatures on this
book plus we never published at any
place else this is the only place to get
the clerk 3 sound uh screenplay Take it
Away Joe 265 and 27 265 270 270 270 270
265 270 265 270 707070 270 265 270 265
270 270 265 270 270 270 300 wow took a
jump 305 3 305 305 3 305 3 305 3 305 305
310 35 310 3 310 310 get 310 get 310 get
310 get 310 320 320 now 25 320 by 325
320 by 325 get 320 325 325 by 330 325
330 325 400 400 about 405 4 about 405 4
about 405 55 400 405 4 about 405 think
you could think you should don't let
them have it now come on back 4 about
405 4 about 405 about 4 about 405 going
once 4 about $45 going twice last call
405 they're making me work 410 4 10 410
410 405 and 410 420 420 4 back to 420
quick end it 420 about 4252 425 42 425
going once 42 425 going twice last
call sold
$420
perfect let me tell you something when I
die if they have to show a clip on the
Oscars show that moment right
there
yes that's Crimson um Lot number 51 my
friends is uh my Puck you uh Jersey my
original Puck Jersey uh with colors that
I couldn't stand but we had to rush to
get them made so we wore these and then
I changed the colors later on uh warn by
me what size is it
3x am I right that's what it says on the
board oh there's no way that's an
XL really
yeah it could be it could be an eight
because I used to wear eight XL Jersey
cut uh goalie cut I don't think I think
that's
three it's an 8xl kids hold it out let's
see if you guys can both put it on I
just like to Puck you about it I think
it's cool yes the jur the like Axl looks
like a 5xl
so maybe it's a 5xl point is it's
[__] big kids there you go 350 355
350 355 355 350 355 that is big look at
that 350 355 350 3 like that moment in
Jaws when they saw the shark under the
boat 350 355 350 by 355 350 by 355 3 by
355 3 by 355 places signed on each one
time each on each number and then also
signed on the front Crest cool 355 and
360 355 36 3 355 36 355 360 going once
360 going twice last call sold
$355 online online Internet bidder um
Lot number 52 is uh this is interesting
this is from Jane s Bob reboot um it's
the chronicon screen used backdrop so
when they went to chronicon this is one
of the backdrops the step and repeats uh
used in the flick uh and it's right
there 300 it's pretty big you want to
just hold it up oh now oh no no just to
give you a size there again that gives
no perspective of size online now this
is huge yeah it really is you're going
to need a big wall for this
kids that's got to be cool oh it's 10t I
see it 10t long all right meantime the
beginning
begins 300 305 300 305 300 305 305 300
305 3 305 30 300 305 300 30 300 30 30
300 305 it's so big by the time I sell
it they'll finally have it unraveled 3
305 3 305 3 305 3 305 3 305 going once
300 by $35 going twice last call
sold for $300 online $300 online what's
it say on the tape right there there's
some writing on the
tape and so it
says blue chronicon step and repeat so
it just identifies what it is
interesting um thank you who bought that
in the room or the internet the internet
the internet crazy um number 53 we're
back to hockey Crest this is a secret
stash uh hockey Crest uh that I wore uh
on a couple jerseys can you grab that
one it's pretty big man and it features
all the kids from Comic Book Men done as
Marvel characters so I'm Thanos Jay is
Loki Ming is Spider-Man Brian is Thor
Walter's Captain America Mike is abic is
Iron Man do you sell these in the comic
in your in the secret I never sold them
except we used to make versions of the
Jersey gab but we didn't do all the
designs and stuff so these are one of a
kind when I made them I would make five
of each Crest and two would go on shirts
and the other would go away so this is
one of the ones that went away wow I
love it it's beautiful 125 get about 130
125 get about 130 130 130 130 130 130
125 get about 130 about 130 about 140
140 140 140 140 I got 130 in the back
bit 140 130 135 130 get about 135 get
about 135 get about 135 get about 135
get about 130 get about 135 130 get
about 135 I got 130 in the back bit 135
130 get about 135 get about 135 get
about 130 get about 135 get about 130
get about 135 going once 130 almost took
that as a bit sir you're kind of SC
scratching your head there 130 about 135
going twice he scratching going who
would pay this much for this
[__] so the $130 in the back to the lady
thank you it's a beautiful Crest you'll
be very happy uh Lot Number 54 is yet
another hockey Crest this is from when I
worked on season two of uh Supergirl uh
it features that image from the t-shirt
we did before um so I wore this while I
was making the show 105 and 110 100 and
I 110 110 110 100 and I get 110 110 1 1
11 100 about 110 100 about 11 110 100
about 11 110 100 and about 110 100 and
about 110 going once 105 110 115 1 to 15
15 1155 115 1 to 15 15 15 15 115 110 115
110 115 going once 0 $115 going twice
last
call sold $110 on the left here on the
left J well done thank you for
supporting spot come get you Crest uh
number 55 kids another hockey Crest this
one's the Buddy Christ uh you've seen
this on a number of jerseys we've sold
in the store looks like this um and it's
the Buddy Christ and current bids 100
bucks 100 bid 110 110 get about 110
12121 212121 2131 31313 13130 14040
140140 140140 140 150 150 150 15060
16060 160 160 160 170 170 170 170 170
170 170 180 180 180 180 180 180 180 180
180 180 It's Only Money Now 180 190 190
190 190 190 190 now 200 2 200 2 two
about two and a quarter two and a
quarter two and a quarter 21 210 help
you 210 210 it's only 210 220 220 220
2202 220 220 220 got 210 220 210 220 21
220 21 220 2 I'll sign it too and he'll
sign it 220 220 who2 220 220 230 30 230
get by 230 get by 230 get by 230 he's
going to sign it 230 230 240 240 240 get
by 240 get 230 get 240 get by 230 get by
240 230 get 240 get 230 sign both sides
Joe there you buy both sides 240 230 get
by 240 get by 230 get by 240 get 240 get
by 240 going once 230 get by 2 H 235 is
that a bid yes 235 240 240 240 245 245
245 245 245 245 240 get by 245 240 get
by 245 I got 240 in the audience been
245 240 get by 245 going once 240 get
about
$245 going twice last call I'm good sold
$240 on the back right thank you all for
bid thank you all forid thank you for
supporting SP Castle Cinemas uh next up
another hockey Crest kids this is uh the
silent Rogue uh hockey Crest because
it's uh the Droid from Rogue one
uh with a backwards baseball cap and a
joint in his mouth as you can see my
jerseys were very
themed 75 and 80 75 and 8088 80 80 80 80
80 75 and 80 80 80 80 80 75 and 80 80 80
75 and 80 80 8080 come on now 8080 75
and 80 75 80 80 75 and 80 80 75 and 80
75 and 80 75 and 80 80 80 80 80 80 going
what yes 7580 going twice last call 80
in time thank you now sniped at the
last plays on the screen here that's it
85 five going once going twice last call
sold $80 in the back thank
you another hockey Crest this one's uh
Darth Blazer man Darth Bob right there
hocky Crest Darth Vader with a backwards
baseball cap and Joint in his mouth take
it away yeah
right smoking hard 80 now five 885 8585
8599 85 in the back 90
999999 going once 8590 going twice last
call sold $85 in the back nice buy well
done thank you next up Lot number 58 is
another hockey Crest TK 420
Stormtrooper uh it's a stormtrooper with
a backwards baseball cap kind of and a
joint in his mouth 85
hey
9998 9998 9898 98 90 going once I got
$85 online B $90 going twice last
call $85 on the thank you out there on
the internet for supporting
us uh Lot number 59 my friends is a
movies hat screen worn from the motion
picture Jay and Silent Bob Strike Back
uh when you do wardrobe on movies you do
three of everything uh there was uh
three of
this nice yeah lot of [__]
DNA um say again who wore it silent
BB oh it says movies SC yeah it's my hat
it's Silent Bob hat I was coming at you
like you idiot but there's no real
information I'm the [__] idiot here
especially if I'm arguing with somebody
who might buy my
hat you know who wore it whoever you
want to wear it man um all right man we
we start the bidding at 350 bucks go
ahead 350 355 350 get by 355 get bu 355
360 360 3 3 3 360 3 3 3 3 360 3 360 is
it on there back there or no I'm sorry
here we go yeah we're at 355 355 at 360
thank you 355 get by 360 get by 355 and
360 355 B 360 going once a jump 380 385
380 380 380 380 38 380 38 380 38 385
going once 380 going to buy 385 sir you
want me
385 thank you 385 390 390 buy 390 you
know and now I need like a crap sper I
need a a mirror right here I need the
mirror to see behind me 385 390 395 3
400 410 400 410 410 405 4 405 4 405 400
405 4 405 4 405 410 410 410 410 410 10
10 10 410 41 about 410 I got 405 and 410
sweating everything
410 41 4 410 410 425 now 430 I got 425
and 430 4 430 about 430 about 430 425
about 430 42 about 430 about 430 about
425 B 430 going once about $430 going
twice last call 500 oh [__] thank you
internet this is like the ton you know
what's it going to be out yes truly 500
5055 505 5 55
50055 55 55 55 going once 500 505 going
twice last
call sold 500 hours nice buy on the
internet thank you internet all right
man Lot number 60 kids is a classic uh
vope vulgarians Jersey came from my
closet what size is
that yeah it's faded that's true says
large and it wasn't mine but I I don't
really well either way it's uh it is
vintage as [__] it was made from the air
and what I'll do is I'll sign the
numbers and I'll sign the crest and I
think there's bids on it 200 go 200 by
205 200
21 210
205 205 210 205 this is not Kevin Smith
hocky Jersey it's Jason Muses go ahead
210 two 2 two two two 2 two 2 t 205 get
210 210 215 thank you 25 220 220 get 220
get 220 get 25 get by 220 250 get by 220
250 get 220 get 220 get 250 get 220 get
220 get 25 get
$220 250 220 going once 215 220 225 225
now 230 230 23 23 230 225 2302 230 2 230
2 230 230 230 230 230 230 get by 230
going once 230 235 240 240 get by 240
get by 240 get by 240 I got 235 out here
bid
240 40 40 40 40 235 4035 4035 40 40 235
bid 40 going once 240 245 250 250 250
250 250 250 250 250 250 250 250 2 250
245 in the audience with 250 4 250 250
250 245 250 255 260 260 get 200 get 60
get 260 2 260 2505 260 250 26 by $260
going once I got 255 out there bid
$260 going twice 260 265 270 270 by 270
get by 270 by 27 get by 270 260 270 265
270 265 get by 270 70 get by 70 by 265 B
270 going once 270 275 280 280 280 280
280 275 by 280 275 by 280 275 280 by 280
get by 280 going once 275 and
$280 going twice last call 290 290 300
or 290 but 285 290 but 295 rather I have
290 I skipped them up to 290 but 295 295
295 by 295 by 295 295 by 295 I got 29
300 310 305 30 305 don't want to after
all that you're sitting here I'm just oh
I appr we appreciate that but we want
another $5 out of you 305 3 305 3 305 3
305 3 305 going once 3 305 hour going
twice last
call and I sold it for $300 online thank
thank you all
forid halfway is that right we're a
little over the halfway mark Ernie says
and we emptied one of our buckets so
productivity uh kids Lot number 61 is
the Superman Liv script from the reading
uh script reading we did here back in
July and it's signed by the people who
read the script Kevin Smith ero Donald
Harley Quinn Smith shabon Fallon Hogan
Austin Zager Mike zapi and uh Ming CH
and the opening bid is 210 210 210 215
210 15 15 15 15 15 220 220 220 220 250
get 220 250 get 220 get 220 get 220 get
250 get 220 250 get 220 get 220 get 250
get 220 250 get 220 250 get 220 get 220
get 220 get 220 get 250 get 220 going
once 215 mid 220 now 225 now 230 230 now
5 235 get by 235 I got 230 here but 235
23 about 235 23 about 235 about 235 23
about 235 about 235
23235 going once
23235 going twice last call sold $230
second row thank you both for bidding
thank you Kenny right here in the room
no l all right
K that's true you're part of it you get
to tag it and you're there Kenny came up
and rev with us he did like one or two
of the lines on the side uh okay no
current bid moving
on what oh oh what size what size are
they good question I would say if they
were made for me they're nine and a
halfs nine and a
halfs all right he'll be
200 200 done and done we got 200 $2 bid
in the room for these 200 205 let's tell
them what they are these are uh they're
Devils of of flavored shoes they have 37
on the side and inside on the tongue it
says Kevin Smith is the devil and they
did my initials KS is like the New
Jersey Devil's logo a prototype pair
that etes never went to Market with but
I have this pair and another pair at
home so I got 200 205 200 205 20 205 205
205 2 by 205 going once 200 by $25 going
twice let's call
sold for $200 thank you sir thank you
thank you yeah we're just going to move
on all right next up is uh number 63
solent Bob screen worn costume shirt
from the movie Clerks 2 uh the bidding
starts at uh 450 what it is kids is it's
a waffle thermal shirt but rather than
wear an undershirt underneath I just had
them cut out the top of the undershirt
and sew it into the shirt so it looks
like I have double shirts on and the
same at the bottom so really it's only
one garment that just has t-shirt stuff
sewn onto it so it looks like I'm
wearing two garments and that just shows
you how artificial and fake Hollywood
is 450 455 45 I get about 55 55 55 55 55
455 455 460 460 460 460 460 460 460 460
460 455 get by 460 460 get 460 455 get
by 460 about 4 6 about 4 6 4 55 and 4
6500 thank you 500 5 10 600 610 6 60 6
61 60 I got 600 get 610 600 610 600 610
get 610 1,000 $1,000 thank you bit
$100,000
b1100 11,000 B 11100 th000 bit 1100
th000 bit 1100 we could try to 1005 1005
I
I got the 1100 thank you now 12 11 by
1200 11 by 1200 11 12 12 12 12 11 1200
1200 1200 12 12 11 1105 1105 in 1110
11:05 in 1110 1110 1110 1110 1110 get
1110 111 get 1110 1105 at 1110 11:05 at
1110 going once 11:05 at 1110 going
twice I can't believe someone's going to
lose it for $15 that makes no sense to
me that was their line man they're like
[__] not a penny more there you got
1105 11 if it if it was clerks 3 maybe
but not Clerks 2 got
it
1205 1210 12 1210 12 1210 12 1210 1250
1255 12 get 1255
1255 1255 get 12 1255 get 12 1255 Now 60
12 60 12 60 12 55 get by 12 60 12 55 get
by 12 60 get by 60 12 1300 1305 1300 by
1305 1300 by 1305 1300 by 1305 1305 and
1310 1305 1310 1305 13 1400 1405 1400
1405 1400 get 1405 1400 by 1405 1400 by
1405 come on ladies 1405 at 1410 145
bucks yeah 1410 [__] nuts man 410 I
told you it was one shirt right like
it's not two sh 1405 B 1410 1405 about
1410 1405 B 1410 1405 at 1410 going once
1405 at 1410 going twice last
call sold it for
$1,445 on the internet thank you you
generous internet Soul
Heavens oh it won 14450 but we closed
right you tell
me it closed at
wait you tell me or we're
still I made a mistake I'm sorry I did
not sell it you never have to apologize
all the good is yours the bad is ours
there you go you're a wholesome thing um
next up kids we've got
lot 64 it's a uh signed grassy script
collection oh there's no current bid
move
on5 125 take it away 125 now 130 125 get
about 130 get about 130 get about 140
140 140 140 140 140 140 140 140 140 140
150 150 you're in already 130 140 want I
be 140 140 150 now back to you 150 160
160 160 170 170 170 170 170 170 170 170
170 170 180 180 180 180 180 180 180 180
180 180 180 180 175 I'll beg 175 I got
170 been 175 175 175 175 180 185 185 185
185 185 185 185 yes there are seven
scripts 200 from three different
episodes I got 200 now bid 210 210 220
220 220 220 220 220 220 2 time 220 220
get 220 get 220 get about 220 22 20 20
get 220 get 220 get 2 get 220 get 220
get 220 220 230 230 240 240 get by 240
get by 240 get by 240 get 240 one more
time 240 250 260 260 260 260 260 It's
Only Money 260 260 260 270 270 280 280
280 280 280 280 270 280 290 290 290 now
300 300 300 about 3 and A4 3 and A4 325
350 350 350 350 350 350 350 350 start
off the new year right 350 3 3 3 325 and
350 32 by 335 help you 335 325 335 325
335 going once 32 by 335 going twice
last
call sold
$325 right over here thank you both for
bidding whether you're here in the room
or whether you're bidding online man uh
we here at SM Castle SS appreciate all
the sport all this money goes keeping
our [__] lights on next up uh number
65 is a Stanley signed poster from a
Stanley event but I don't know if he
actually signed this I roll I'll roll it
out yeah he [__] signed it okay so
this was when um Stan got his feet in
the cement at the Chinese Theater
theater uh the TCL Chinese Theater out
in Los Angeles uh groans uh I was the MC
and whatnot uh this is the poster that
they put together for the event and Stan
has tagged it in a silver Sharpie down
below now sadly we lost the lake great
Stanley so they're not making that
signature anymore crazy [__] rare man
uh so there you go 340 345 345 345 345
345 345 actually very reasonable for
Stanley autograph PR 340 about 345 340
about 345 340 about 345 340 get about
345 340 345 340 345 340 345 340 345 340
345 34 get by 345 going once 340 get by
$345 going twice last
call and I sold it for $340 online
online give it up for Joe give it up for
the winner online
[Applause]
Lot number 68 man it's a Comic Book Men
uh secret stash uh pops uh you've got
Ming from the Comic Book Men Funko
Flagship night uh when uh they open the
store in Washington um and they did a
very limited run of Comic Book Men pops
the other three pops are Walter Brian
and Mike and that's from the secret
stash rendition of those pops a small
run that we had done and and uh all four
of them are signed by the cast of Comic
Book Men all four Comic Book Men that's
cool 500 510 505 rather 5005
5555 55 55 5005
555 going once 500
$55 going twice last call
okay sold it for $500 online thank you
all for
[Applause]
bidding Lot number 67 is the Goodwill
Hunting crew car heart jacket uh that
it's got no current bid so let's move
on wait anybody want to be
500 yeah we can move on we'll do it next
auction uh no bid on this either because
that's the the Jersey I almost died and
let's move on
well [__] it you know if they didn't B
on it yeah but [__] it moving on um this
is uh from uh drop the mic but no
current bid so we can move on I mean
nobody's bidding on it so we might as
well move to stuff that oh [__] this has
a bid this is the HoldEm mcneel Poker
table uh cloth that uh we played on at
my house forever and ever and ever um is
designed I think if I remember correctly
by Ming Chen and uh it's uh you know you
could put it on any poker table it's
ready for what do they call it matting
framing Ernie will hold it up or try to
it's [__] huge it could also be used
as a blanket or a wall
hanging I got
575 this is nice
5805 580 58 58 580 55 58 55 580 55 5 you
get about five and you get about five
get about five get about 600 I see 600
605 thank you 600 by 605 600 by 605 600
by 605 605 605 by 605 650 655 655 all in
655 now 655 660 655 6 6 6 6 655 660 655
going to by 660 how much money did you
make on this table a whole bunch um
never that much I'll say 750 755 750
going to by 755 750 get by 755 750 get
by 755 get by 755 get by 775 now 80 775
and 80 775 and 80 80 80 775 80 775 at 80
775 at 80 775 and 80 I was never good at
playing poker but I definitely enjoy
watching it on TV it is I was just
looking at it from behind it says
December what is it 31st 2003 so that
was the first night we did like poker up
the house we called it casino is cuute
so this is now 21 years
old yeah 21 years old vintage it can
drink this thing's legal 8:30 8:35 8:30
35 30 35 30 35 30
35,50 B a, 55 1,50 get 1,55 get 1,50 get
1,55 1,50 get by,
5550 by55 you're going to autograph it
as well guys he's going to autograph it
right now Kevin Smith is autographing it
1,50 bit th55 1,50
b75 1250 bit 12 55 1250 get 12 55 1250
get 12 55 get 1250 get 1250 1400 1405
1400 1405 1400 1405 1400 1405 1400 1405
1400 1405 going once 140000 get by 1405
going twice last call
sold it for
$1,400 thank you [__] Ernie was just
mocking me because I was like nobody's
gonna want that um but it's sold next
lot kids Lot
number oh what happened to 69 that was
going to be fun was that one of the ones
that we were we skipped
it9 that was 69 we can't go back we
always have to move forward the past is
depression the future is anxiety we have
to be in the moment that's what they
taught me at the booby hatch um let's
move on we'll maybe Circle back later on
number
71 uh we have what we have it it's just
not here but also we sell this in the
stash move
on uh well I mean we're [__] like you
know all right oh [__] this is really
good man [__] item uh Lot number 72
Silent Bob's screen jeans from Jay and
Silent Bob Strike Back so we made that
movie in 2001 these pants are 20 [__]
three years old ladies and gentlemen um
that's uh that's what s remember when
he's like shoot him in the ass that's
what I got shot in the ass wearing um
actual Wardrobe from the picture one of
three of course in movies you triplicate
everything and whatnot so this is the
hero pair that I wore not just in the
movie but I took home and wore for the
next few years as well cuz jeans are
jeans [__] everybody um current bid
starts at 750 Joe take us there there
you go
75755 50 55 get by 755 get 55 55 55 55
55 55 755 755 get by 755 750 755 750 755
750 755 750 755 size 48 by 30 there you
go size
48 750 by 755 750 by 755 by 750 by 755 7
50 7 55 7 50 755 going once 750 B 700 $5
55 going twice last
call sold
$750 on the
internet Lot number uh 73 uh comes from
our good friends at lelu multiprops it
is a m rats image of TS and Brandy
signed by the Stars Jeremy London and
CLA ferani Take it Away Joe I got 200
but 205 200 20 20
205 200 205 200 205 205 205 205 205 210
two 20 210 20 210 2 21 20 210 if you get
a chance or someone could put that back
up I'm sorry I closed it out by accident
205 210 thank you every about that guy
keep turning around even though I can't
tell if I'm turning around or not 225
230 22 230 220 230 220 230 230 230 225
230 225 230 thank you so much 225 230 2
everybody technical
genius save the goddamn day it's it's
it's called multitasking he truly does
225 by 230 225 230 220 225 bid 230 going
once 225 $230 going twice last call sold
$225 on the internet thank you all for
bidding Ernie wants us to do something
that's only in the room that's not
available up there so we have some stuff
let's do the which one do you want yeah
sure so I the only thing I can draw is
Bullwinkle and um I drew them and this
is in honor of today so it's Bullwinkle
it says SM auction
2024 um it's obviously not available to
anybody online but it's here for
auctioning in the room let's start the
bidding at really affordable 20 bucks
$20 okay okay she just jumped to 100
5,000 5,000 all right I got a 100 I hit
100 been one and a quarter one and a
quarter one and a half 150 200 two and a
quarter two and a quarter two and a quar
get bu two and a quter get bu two and a
quar two and a quarter two and a quarter
210 210 help you 210 210 get by 210 I
have the lady here at 200 B 210 200 get
210 get 210 get 210 210 210 20 5 210 215
250 250 250 220
225 230 230 23 23 23 23 23 23 230 230 23
230 he said 237 we have to honor that
number here I'll take the number if
that's what you want 237 you got to
screw me all up
here 238
239 239 240
240 242 244
244 244 244 dude where was I 244 I'm at
what 244 is that right yeah 244
244 it's only $2 more nothing to think
about 244 don't be don't be bullied
neighbor 245 250 245 get 250 get 250 250
you can't all this
way will you take his picture with that
oh of course absolutely 250 250 5 255
255 260 260 260 2 275 300 let's jump it
back up come on you're making me work
too much 300 300 by 300 by 300 275 and
285 275 good man 275 and 300 about 275
and 300 anyone can bid now 275 and 300
going once $275 and $300 going twice
last call nice buy for
$275 did it
[Applause]
come on up meantime let's do uh let's do
the clerk's poster you know what [__] it
let's do that
one do the cler yeah okay let's do
Clerk's poster um tell them tell them
what they got all right what are we
selling there clerks 3 foil poster mini
poster 12 by8 from clerks 3 all the cast
signed by Mr Kevin Smith where is he
[__] you want him to draw B Winkle on
them we'll do it anything you want we'll
do it 300 3 3 3 $1 to go1 to go $50 and
go
6 significant significant 60 70 70 70 70
70 70 $70 $70 70 70 70 60 70 808080 80
80 808080 709 80 709 80 909090 9090 90
90 100 100 100 9 100 get 100 100 100 get
100 9 100 get 100 get 100 sir $100 you
came all this way $100 $100 100 100 get
110 110 110 110 100 11 110 11 110
120 120 where at 120 120 120 I'll take
it wherever it is 120 120 130 130 140
140 get above 140 get above 140 sir 140
140 140 140 you're my 130 bid 140 13 140
140 get 130 get 140 get 140 get 130 get
about 140 I got 100 $130 here on my left
B 140 130 140 140 130 140 130 140 going
once3 to $140 going twice last call sold
$130 right over
there thank you both for
bidding uh let's do the skateboard the
deck what was it 135 how much 130 130
well done uh kids the last little item
we'll do for now in the room is this
beautiful sign deck says Clerk's 30 on
it because it's our 30th Anniversary uh
this year uh made by the good Folks at
lelu multi profs elegant Quick Stop uh
yellow with the clerk's logo and 3x's
and I signed it at the bottom uh
available only here not on the online
auction what do we start at with 500 500
500 300 300 it's like a hoverboard isn't
it 2001 go $100 to go $100 to go one a
qu one and a qu one and a half 175 175
now 2 and a quter 2 and a quter 2 and A2
2 and A2 get 250 2 250 250 250 250 250
275 275 now 300 300 3 and a quarter 3
and a quarter 3 and 1/2 3 and 1/2 3 and
1/2 3 and 1/2 375 375 now 400 400 400 4
and a quarter four and a quarter four
and a quarter four and a quarter 4 and
a/2 4 and a/2 4 and a/2 4 and a/2 450
get about 450 4 about 450 get about 450
think you could think you should 475 475
475 500 500 500 500 500 500 500 get
about 5 and a quter 5 and a quter 5 and
a quter 5 and a quter 5 and a quter 5
and 1/2 5 and 1/2 5 and 1/2 5 and 1/2 5
and 1/2 get about 5 get about 5 550 5 5
550 one more time sir 550 came all this
way 550 575 575 you came all this way
don't miss out now
57575 to BU 600 600 600 600 575 to BU
600 5 75 to BU 600 5 75 600 600 5 75 bid
600 going once 5 75 6 $100 going twice
last call and a quarter six and a
quarter 6 and a quarter I got you don't
worry 600 B 6 and a quarter 6 and a
quarter I'll take you twice if you like
six and a quarter I got him at 600 [__]
6 and a quarter sir 625 come back in 625
625 625 600 625 going once 600 625 going
twice last
call so for
$600 in the blue
[Applause]
thank you for your support of SM Castle
Cinemas that was for the folks right
here in the room now we're going to jump
back to the stuff that everybody could
bid on uh Lot number
74 is uh uh the grassy beanie season
three that I got for working on the show
back in the day me and Jay were on the
show as ourselves and whatnot uh so
there you go it starts at 50 bucks 50
50555 60 55
60 60 55 605 60 60 605 60 going once $55
$60 going twice last
call sold $55 right here nice
Spy Next up kids Lot number 75 we're
getting there man this comes from our
good friends at lelu multiprops this is
a Lorraine brocco signed photo obviously
an image from The Sopranos uh Jersey
royalty around these parts ladies and
gentlemen and the bidding is at 105 Take
it Away Joe that's cheaper than an hour
of therapy right there 105 and 110 10
about 110 115 1 T to5 1 15 15 15 15 115
I got 110 in the backp 115 1 T 15 15 1
15 155 11 15 115 110 bit 115 110 bit 115
110 bit 11 15 110 115 120 120 now 5 125
125 125 125 now 130 130 135 13535 135
135 135 135 135 135 139 135 13 135 13
135 sir 135 13 about 13 130 13 130 13
135 going once
13135 going twice last
call sold $130 straight in the back
thank you for supporting SM Castle
Cinemas kids Lot number 76 is a catch
and release hat that I got for working
on the movie Catch and Release I acted
once had nothing else to do with the
movie but act and for that they gave me
this lovely
hat if if you want I I don't have a do
we have a silver marker I can sign it as
well autographed at all 80 bid five 85
8585 8585 858
85 90 85 90 85 909090 90 90 I got 85 in
the front row bid 90 85 90 I got 85 in
the front row bid 90 85
99999 95 9595 9595 9959 95 just fresh we
autograph guys 90
999999 95 going once 90 95 hours and now
100 I got 95 in 100 95 100 100 100 95
100 100 100 95 100 100 95 100 95 100
going once 95 $100 going
twice 105 105 105 105 105 105 105 105
105 105 he looks like he's going to go
skateboarding now with that skateboard
100it 105 100it
105 100 100 going once get $5 going
twice last call so the $100 on online
thank you all for bidding thank you all
for
bidding I see you looking for you
looking for the Lorraine Bronco winner
did somebody win that in the room the
lorine brocko hey him he's got it Connor
was looking for he wants his [__]
money um okay Lot number 77 is a yoga
hoser H sign poster uh signed by Kevin
Smith the guy responsible for this and
uh signed by Harley Quinn Smith uh the
his kid his only begotten daughter that
he forced to be in this movie
Uh current bidding is 100
bucks I'm
sorry 110 10 11 110 110 110 5 get 10 10
1 10 110 110 110 110 105 110 105 110 105
110 105 110 105 110 going once $15 of
$110 going twice last call sold 105
hours right over here Dead Center thank
you thank you for sporting SP Cinema and
my kid every time I put something up
with her signature on it she [__]
dies a thousand deaths because she's
like what if nobody bids on it so you
made my kid very happy thank you um okay
number 78 is a signed Banky print signed
by Jason Lee who played the character
Banky Jason Lee has been to SM Castle uh
two times in the past he's coming back
again to do a My Name is Earl thing uh
but while he's here he always signs
stuff first that we auction before the
screenings go off this is one of those
take it away I got 125 get about 130 125
get about 13 130 130 130 130 130 130 now
5 now 5 now 5 135 135 135 35 about 135 I
got 130 get about 135 130 about 135 130
about 13 about 135 about 13 135 about 13
135 135 about 135 about 150 thank you
155 155 get about 155 155 now 160 160
160 160 160 155 get about 160 160 15 get
about 160 155 on my back left B 160 155
get about 160 160 155 get 160 160 155
get 160 160 going once $155 been $160
going
twice last call are we good I see it's
refreshing but are we good 175 online
thank you 175 180 180 180 180 180 man
want to be 180 It's Only Money now it's
it's like buying some popcorn 180 185
what get 185 185 I got 180 bid 185 180
bid 185 180 bid 185 180 bit 185 180 been
185 going once 180 in the back left B
185 going twice last call 190 thank you
195 195 she says she's out I don't know
190 been
195 195 195 don't have buyers remorse
for not buying it believe me I've done
that plenty of times I've gone home and
went you know what I should have bid on
that I should just went that what extra
bid 190 bid 195 190 bid 195 190 get 195
going once 190 get about 195 going twice
last call and I sold it for
$190 interet for whoever bought it every
for
Joe moving right along man a lot 79 is a
signed Superman lives print from when we
did the Superman lives script reading uh
I signed it right on our Superman's fist
uh and should sign it Brainiac should
sign it that means Ernie should sign it
Ernie played Brainiac so you should tag
it as well so you'll also get [__]
Ernie signature as well
man Castle keeper R o' Donnell uh we
only made a few of these only for the
folks who went to the screening right
everybody got one so if you weren't
there you didn't get one here's your
chance 135 140 140 140 140 140 140 140
135 get about 140 get 140 get 135 get
about 140 135 get about 140 135 get
about 140 140 get 135 get about 140 get
about 140 get 140 140 get 135 get about
140 get 135 get about 140 going once $1
135 hours been $140 going twice last
call sold $1 135 hours online
[Applause]
online uh what time do we start 2
o'clock a little after two so we've been
doing this for a little over two hours
man everyone okay we're almost done two
and a half hours Ernie's been timing us
yall having a good time so far I'm in
for where we're watching the movie we
still auctioner yes [__] it we'll keep
doing it uh you all having a good time
kids not much more to go and all of this
goes to support SM Castle Cinema so
thank you so much from the bottom of my
heart bottom Ernie's heartless [__]
heart and everybody Ashley everybody
here SM Castle Cinemas uh Lot number 80
is a small town gay bar poster signed by
both me and the director Malcolm Ingram
Malcolm Ingram Ingram is here what's
that that's Malcolm ladies and gentlemen
sitting in the
back uh I got it from uh in my house
they I was it was as I was cleaning the
office I was like holy [__] I have one
of these you'd already signed
it well start bidding
[__] it's a poster that not even
the director has ladies and gentlemen
that's how rare it is take it away 95 in
100 95 100 get to 110 100it 110 110 110
100it 105 105 100 105
it to you if you're in the room if you
buy it in the room yeah there you go 100
bit 105 I got 100 bit 105 105 105 105
105 105 100it 105 100it 105 105 105 105
100 get 105 get 105 105 105 get 105
going once 125 130 130 130 130 130 125
130 130 130 130 130 55 135 130 get about
135 get about 135 get 135 get 130 get
about 135 130 get about 135 130 get
about 135 get 130 get about 135 get
about 135 13 get about 135 going once
130 135 hours going twice last call
we're good
13 uh 130 I had 130 back there but okay
will be 135 thank you 135 140 now it's
his turn to be 140 140 140 140 140 130
about 140 13 about 140 140 130 140 130
140 130 140 going
once oh boy 140 150 150 160 160
160 16050 160 155 he is not bidding but
we could take him in 150 155 15 get
about 155 get about 155 get about 155
get about 155 I got 150 in the backp 155
155 155 155 get 150 155 going once am I
good to go 150 1
15 oh my God 200 210 210 210 210 210 210
205 20
20 205 210 I got 205 in the back with
210 20 2 2 2 210 205 210 205 bid 210
going once 205 bid $210 going twice last
call am I good to go sold $25 in the
back congratulations thank you make sure
Malcolm's personalized it to you s
you're G to give it to him give it up
he's giving Malcolm as [__] poster
back just beautiful Malcolm can we re
auction it right
now okay kids Lot number 81 uh similar
to the Banky print that Jason Lee signed
this is a brody print uh drawn by the
great Steven silver uh he drew the other
one as well and uh the bidding is at 70
bucks Take it Away Joe 79 75
75555 8 now 8 now8 I got 758 85 85 85 85
85 85 85 85 I got 80 way in the back 85
85 85 85 85 85 85 885 9 9 95 95 95 I got
90 behind me been 95 95 95 95 95 I got
90 to the internet here been 95 am I
correct I got 90 B 95 95 been 100 95 100
100 100 100 100 get to 110 100 110 110
110 100 110 110 100 110 100 online 110
120 120 120 120 120 120 13 13 1 1 30 130
130 130 130 130 130 130 140 140 get
about 140 get about 140 get 140 get 140
get 130 get about 140 get 140 get 140
get 140 130 140 130 get 140 get 140 get
130 140 get 130 get 140 get 130 140
going once so there's no confusion I got
$130 in the back bid 140 the internet's
out correct 140 you want to be in 130
yep 130 bid 140 130 140 130 140 going
once 13 to 140 going twice last
call 140 150 she snuck in there 150 150
150 150 150 150 15050 160 160 160 160
160 160 160 15060 you didn't get the
other one you know you want this one 160
170 170 170 170 170 it's not a dig I'm
just telling the truth 170 170 17 160
170 160 170 17060 170 17060 170 160 170
160 170 going once 160 B 170 going twice
last CAU 170 180 180 180 180 180 170 180
180 1780 1780 17180 17180 17180 going 1
170 been 180 going twice last call sold
$170 back
left excellent
job uh okay the next lot my friends Lot
number
82 is the uh SM Castle Cinema's uh
silence your phone uh sign that's in our
lobby uh Jason and I signed Jesus it's
up to $500 ho I know we're you guess
what that's all we're selling from now
on no more movies just this thing over
and over again till everyone in America
has one for 50 bucks 500 bucks [__] Take
it Away Joe 500 about 55 500 5555 5005
555 55 55 5
5555 5 55 5 55 5 55 going once World 500
$55 going twice last
call so $500 online $500 internet winner
that was drawn by the Great Dark Nate
Gonzalez man he does a lot of artwork
including this artwork uh for lot number
83 for the clerks open all night uh
screening event we had last year in
March um it's signed by Kevin Smith uh
Jason Muse Brian o' hollerin and Jeff
Anderson uh the only person who was at
the event was Kevin Smith but those
other three they signed it because
they're nice kids and they want to
support the cinema and we are at 500
bucks yeah 500 505 55 5 5
5555 55 55 5 55 5 55 5 55 5 55 55 5 55
going once 500 5005 going twice last
call and I sold it for $500 to the
internet thank you for supporting SM
Castle Cinemas uh we are at 84 my
friends and 84 is the Chasing Amy event
poster uh that we used for the uh 26th
anniversary last year of Chasing Amy
when Jason Lee uh came to do the
screening and Q&A uh first time he had
been here and he had well first or
second second time because he'd come
with M rats and he loved it so much he's
like I want to come like every quarter
so he's coming back as well uh he signed
it and I I'll sign it as well and right
now the bidding starts at whatever it 85
85 90 85 909 now 9595 9595 95 90 up
front here B 95
9595 95 9 95 99 95 99 95 I got 90 up
front here B 95 get 95 get 95 get 90 get
95 get 90 get 95 get 90 get 95 going
once 90 $95 going twice 100 I see now
110 105 sir 105 going to be 105 105 get
105 105 105 105 get 105 get 105 105 get
105 get 105 105 105 105 going once $15
going twice last
call sold the $100 online thank you all
for
bidding Lot number 85 is the Chasing Amy
Crossroad side print not the original of
course that hangs up in Jane s Bob
secret stash uh but we took the original
made a copy had Jason Lee sign it as his
character is the one that draws it Banky
and Chasing Amy and I signed the lower
right corner the art is actually by
Scott moer 350 355 350 355 350 355 35
355 3 355 get 3 355 3 355 3 355 get 3
355 3 355 3 355 going once 350 bit 3
$355 going twice last
call and we sold it for the $350 bid
onl that's wonderful thank you so much
man because it cost us like 20 cents to
make um here we go kids Lot number 86 is
uh I like this very much the opening
credits of Chasing Amy uh had different
news articles about the rise of the
career of uh Holden uh and Banky and so
uh comic shop news which like I read
every week when I went to comic book
stores um we had them do like their
version of the story of our main
characters so Hooper X is represented
with his artwork Alyssa Jones with
idiosyncratic routine and Holden and
Banky are represented not by blunt man
and chronic because this stage in their
career they hadn't created blunt man and
chronic yet it's the artwork for a black
and white book they did called 37 and
the artwork is done by the great Walter
Flanigan so this is a crazy rare piece
Jason Lee signed it and I signed it as
well it's not the original it's a yeah
no I got the original [__] all y'all uh
but we took it to a printer and how to
make nice versions and had Jason Lee
sign 95 in 100 95 100 100 100 get 100
100 get 100 110 105 rather 105 105 105
105 105 105 105 105 105 105 105 105 105
105 105 105 105 get 105 get 105 105 get
105 105 going once $105 going twice last
call $100 online $100 online thank you
online
bidder uh kids Lot number 87 is from our
good Folks at Lelo multiprops it is a
Breaking Bad don't scroll well I'm
reading still uh Breaking Bad Le the
multiprops exclusive sign blue foil
print it's limited and numbered and here
here's who signed it you got Aaron Paul
you got Mark margalus you got Anna gun
who I worked with in Red State you got
Dean Norris you got RG mitt you got
Danielle and Lewis monata Raymond Cruz
stepen Michael Gaza Charles Baker and
Matt Jones it's a lot of [__]
signatures for people that were uh in
Breaking Bad and the starting bid is 425
425 430 430 get about 430 about 430
about 425 about 430 get about 430 about
4 25 get about 430 4 about 430 about 425
about 430 about 430 about 425 about 430
about 430 about 430 430 about 430 a
whole lot of autographs on here guys 4
25 about 430 42 about 430 4 25 about 430
about 425 bid 430 going once or 2 about
$430 going twice last
call sold it for
$425 on the
internet next up we got lot number 88
this is a two pack here a Carney trade
paperback and an issue one the secret
stash variant uh signed by author Brian
Johnson so you get two Carney books uh
one is the trade BB and one is the
single issue of issue number one 7 now
75 7 75 75 75 75 75 7 75 75 75 75 75 7
75 7 75 75 7 75 7 75 75 7 757 75 7 75
7575 775 going once 7 $75 going twice
last
call and we sold it online $75 thank you
online
buyer Lot number 89 my friends is a
Hollywood Babylon poster signed by me
and Ralph Garmin Ralph Garmin signature
is up there but I just signed it this
morning so you got uh both of us uh
crazy rare we don't make these anymore
but this is when the show first
incarnation of the show and the bidding
is at
105 I like the say up top 105 at 110 105
110 110 110 110 105 1105 110 105 110 110
110 10 110 110 110 110 110 11 105 110
105 110 105 110 going once 105 of $110
going twice last
call sold online15 thank you internet
for supporting spast of Cinemas Lot
number 90 my friends um
is um this is from our good friends of
lelu multi props it's a Bray Wyatt
signed figure man if you're a a
wrestling fan um there it is signed by
Brett White and it's up to 200 Bray
white and it's up to 205 bucks 205 210
210 205 2 205 210 205 2 2 205 bid 210
going once 205 bid
$210 going twice last
call sold $25 online online thank you to
the winner and thank you to our good
friends at lelu multiprops next up lot
91 I can't believe we're going to get to
two to two to 100 I I'm I'm so happy lot
91 Maul rat signed post uh drawn by dark
Nate Gonzalez our friend who does most
of the artwork for uh here at span
Castle Cinemas this was to celebrate the
mallat screening we had on January 21st
that Jeremy and uh and Jason were both
at and it's signed by Jason Lee and
Jason Muse did I sign it and it's signed
by Kevin Smith as well take it away
there you go 185 190 195 195 out 200 200
get 200 200 get get 200 195 up front
here bid 200 195 get 200
195 195 200 205 205 205 210 210 210 2
205 210 205 210 25 220 225 225 225 225 I
got 220 in the front row b 225 220 about
225 225 225 now 230 230 235 I got 230
now in the second row but 235 235 about
235 235 23 235 23 235 23 235 23 235
going once to 350 I see now 350 355 355
get by 355 get by 355 with a big jump
there right it wasn't just me I wasn't
in I was in the 200s right yeah okay f
it screwed me up there oh 400 thank you
400 405 I was thinking a Time warper son
405 wow 4 about 405 4 about 405 about
400 about 405 400 about 405 get about
400 about 405 about 400 405 about 400
about 405 going once 400 about
$45 going twice last
call and we sold it for $400 online
thank you all for
bidding you sold it for that much [__]
you're good man thank you um okay 92 Lot
number 92 is a j oh it's got no bid move
on uh 93 m Lot number 93 is M rat's
fantastic 2 print
um it's signed by Jason Lee I believe I
tagged it this morning as well and it's
signed by me as well this was the
artwork for Priscilla Barnes uh Miss
Ivana in the opening credits M it's not
the original it's a duplicate but it's
signed by Jason Lee and me we never
really made it available so it was only
here it's mastle and here it is I got a
$34 bid
30439 oh boy 304 get 309 get 309 get 309
get 309 I feel like your guys are
punking me today 304 309 304 get 309 I
just got to roll with the punch 304 309
304 get by 309 304 get by 309 get 304
get 309 get 304 get 309 304 get by 309
39 314 39 get by 314 39 get 314 get 314
get 314 314 314 get by 314 319 314 get
by 319 319 319 get by 319 get by 319 get
by 39 319 get by 319 314 B 319 314 B 319
1 319 B 324 324 B 329 324 B 329 324 B
329 324 get by 329 324 get by 329 going
once 324 B 329 going twice last
call 334 329 334 forcing you to use your
arithmetic skills today oh my goodness
329 334 329 334 334 B 339 334 get
334 334 339 334 339 you know new
auctioneers we should put into a hot
seat like this and have to do like
different odd numbers truly just off the
hell of it you know 339 it is a skill
339 with 33 344 339 by 344 339 by 344
going once 334 bid 3 339 mid 344 going
twice last
call 339 with 344 339 with 344 339 3 44
339 344 339 344 going once 339 344 going
twice let's
call sold for
$339 buyer number internet thank you
internet buyer which adds to 69 it does
add to 69 holy [__] [__] clever well
done well played uh okay uh number Lot
number 94 is the bear is driving print
we did for the clerk's cartoon Marathon
uh we held it back in when was it July
so uh it's signed by Brian oh' Hollin
Jeff Anderson and Kevin Smith three
people who are involved with the clerk's
cartoon 205 215 205 2 250 2 250 25 205
and 215 205 and 215 205 250 2 205 215
205 250 205 250 25 250 205 215 going
once 205 and 215 now words go in twice
last
call sold $25 online $25 online online
bitter 95 Lot number 95 is a chronicon
lanyard uh and it's signed by Kevin
Smith Jason Muse Jason Lee and Harley
Quinn Smith four people who were in Jane
Silent Bob reboot where the lanyard was
BN I got 300 305 300 305 305 300 305 3
305 3 305 3 305 3 305 3 305 3 305 3 305
going once three by $35 going twice last
call and we sold it for $300 online $300
online moving right along kids Lot
Number 96 is a Dante's death sign print
by Phil Hester and Andy Parks it's uh
alternate cover to quick stops my comic
book series uh number two it features uh
Randall holding uh his dead cousin Brody
in an homage if you will to uh the cover
of crisis of in on infinite Earths that
was done by the late great George Perez
um it is signed by me it is signed by
Jeff Anderson and it is signed by Brian
oh' holler and all of whom are depicted
on in the artwork it's not the original
this is a copy uh we sold the original
that's right you got the original yeah
you sold it I sold it for you he bought
it let's resell it let's go around and
around that's true that's how life goes
150 bid 155 150 155 now 160 160 160 160
155 160 160 160 160 155 1605 160605
160605 1605 1605 160605 160605 160605
160 160 going once now I forgot who I
had I had 155 here right yeah I thought
so in the audience 160 155 160 155 160
going twice last
call sold $155 in the front row here
thank you for bidding thank you for
bidding well
done uh next up Lot number 97 we've got
a blank kev's Jersey one of my jerseys
uh it's a 4XL uh that's what of course I
would have the crest sewn onto so this
was one that didn't have a Crest Zone
onto it it was one of my last blanks so
you can put anything you want on the
front of it including a Crest if you
want or somebody else's Crest and I've
signed both numbers on the back there
you go
30035 300 by 305 3 by 305 300 305 5 300
305 3 305 3 305 305 305 3 305 300 305 3
305 3 by 305 it's a great Jersey ladies
and gentlemen 300 305 300 305 3 305 300
305 going once 300 by $35 going twice
last call 305 thank you 310 I got 305 in
the back with 310 305 at 310 35 3 10 3
10 305 3 10 305 3 10 305 3 10 going once
305 3 10 going twice last
call so $35 in the back boom thank
you Lot number 98 kids is a Big Bang
Theory Jersey that they gave me when I
came and guested on the show um on the
back it says my name and uh a number and
on the front is their logo as a gift
from the folks that uh made the Big Bang
Theory and uh it starts at 250 bucks 250
255 255 260 260 260 260 350 350 375 350
375 3 I'm sorry 500 thank you 5 and a
quarter triple x 500 5 and a quarter 5
and a quarter 500 been 5 and a qu 500
been 5 and a quarter 500 about 525 I got
500 there bid 505 500 about 505 500 505
5005 55 5 55 55 5 55 going once 500 by
$55 going twice last call so for $500
thank you sir right over there we
appreciate it very
much I see you every day when I edit the
movie uh sorry kids just taking a second
to tag if you will here you go many
thanks thank you um folks if you're at
home watching we're almost hitting our
100th item we've been having a [__]
blast doing this kids in the room having
a good time or you had a St oh they're
having a good time um this is all in
support of SM Castle Cinemas but this
ain't the only thing we do we actually
show movies here and have events and
stuff for example tonight we'll be
showing the 15th anniversary screening
of Zach and Mary um I'm coming back for
the weekend of January 20th uh because
we're doing for the second time uh
clerks open all night where you come
here at 11 o'clock at night we lock the
doors you can wear your pajamas and we
just show clerks all night long until
the sun comes up and stuff uh after that
the day after that we're doing Batman
returns and then February we don't have
a and Space Balls is also on January
20th in the afternoon uh so cool events
if you're out there watching you're like
oh [__] I'll go to that uh come join us
tickets at SM Castle cinemas.com okay
right now we're at Lot number 99 the
great one man it's uh from our good folk
friends at lelu multiprops um it is the
better call Saw cast sign print and it's
signed by can we scroll up a little bit
or there you go Dean Norris stepen
Michael Gaza Raymond Cruz Lis monata and
I missed the last name it went so fast
but there it is bidding starts at one
Daniel monata uh the building starts at
110 take it away 110 115 110 get 15 1550
150 150 110 get 150 get 150 get 115 110
bit 115 110 bit 115 110 bit 115 110 bit
115 110 bit 115 110 bit 115 going once I
got 110 online bit
$115 going twice SL
call sold the $110 online $110
online uh Ernie wanted me to R remind
folks as well that the thing is starting
what
day what is it next Wednesday we're
running the thing for a week or
something like that John Carpenter's
thing so if you've ever wanted to see
the thing on the big screen or if you've
seen the thing on the big screen you're
like I'd want to do it again come join
us
here you want to see the thing on the
big screen
yeah that was exactly as dirty as we
meant it um okay now we're up to did we
finish this or no yes that's gone so
then we're up to uh item 100 lot 100
Kids is a clerks and Clerks 2 screenplay
signed by Kevin Smith so the first one
is the old printing that mirax book did
Max books did years ago of the clerk
screenplay and the Chasing Amy
screenplay both under one cover and the
other is the graffiti designs uh
printing of the Clerks 2 the entire
Clerks 2 screenplay and I signed both
take it away 270 but 275 270 275 27 275
27 275 270 275 27 275 27 275 2 7 25 2 2
75 2 2 75 going once 270 bid
$275 going twice last
call 300 300 by 305 300 by 305 300 by
305 300 by 305 3 by 305 305 300 305 300
310 315 31 315 310 315 310 35 35 310 315
310 315 3 T by 315 3 T by 315 3 T by 315
going once 3 bid
$315 going twice last
call so $310 online $310
online do we go for it we keep
going all right so it's 2 o'clock in Los
Angeles which means it's five o'clock
here you say like half hour a little bit
we do have to flip the place for like uh
for um the Zach and M screening later on
so but let's
go yeah we hit 100 let's try to go to
110 any Jersey Girls the room's full of
them
sir um all right let's go for it man Lot
number 101 comes from our good friends
at lelu multiprops man it's Beerfest
cast sign posters signed by Kevin
heffernon Jay chandri gar Steve lemy and
Eric stansky man uh the bidding starts
at 150 bucks 155 160 160 160 160 160 155
get 160 16060 1505 160 160505 160 1505
16060 1505 160505 160 15 155 get about
160 160 165 170 170 170 170 170 165 and
170 165 get about 170 170 165 170 170
165 170 165 170 going once 165 in $170
going twice last call sold $165 nice buy
excellent job
Lot number 102 kids is a signed A to Z
jacket is it signed well I can sign it
um it is the jacket that uh the cast
wore um to promote Yogo oers when we
went to Sundance we got a bunch of these
Coates and they have the a to zed uh
logo from the fake convenience store in
that movie and Kevin Smith will sign it
right under the
logo and the opening bid is what 180 B
185 180 185 185 185 185 185 190 190 190
190 190 19 190 19 colia Jack warm as
[__] 185 190 190 185 get 190 I got 185
in the front row left B 190 185 get 190
I got 185 on my left B 190 190 190 185
190 190 190 185 about 190 going once $15
about $190 going twice last call sold
the 185 hours of my left good job
anybody buys any yogos or anything Owns
My Heart thank you man well done yes
absolutely I ain't going to leave you
hanging 103 kids lot3 is the grassy the
movie Pitch outline binder this is what
they brought to me when they were like
we want you to direct the movie and it's
got the entire outline of the story
inside so it's not the script it was
before the script was even made um and
it's got to cover the features pictures
of the cast and it has the epitome card
inside so lots of pages it looks like
your typical pitch deck it tells you
where the story is going to go 125 130
125 13 130 130 13 13 12 12 130 13 13 13
13 13 13 13 1325 13 135 135 135 135 135
130 about 135 13 135 135 13 get 135 get
130 get 135 get 130 get 135 going once I
got 130 here been 135 going twice last
call sold the $130 buyer number right in
the room well done there is no number
but yes on the third row um thank you
for your support Lot number 104 is a
signed cast print from the movie The
Sand lot and it features uh the entire
cast of well not the entire cast but a
lot of kids of the characters except for
one everybody but
who there it is um so everyone but but
Benny um take it away 325 and 330 325
330 330 330 325
330 330 3 3 35 3 35 3 35 33 by 325 bid
330 going once 325 by
$330 going twice last
call sold online for
$325
yes thank you to the buyer and thank you
to the good friends at lelu multiprops
for the donation okay Lot number
105 is uh Breaking Bad cast signed
poster also from lelu multiprops uh who
signed it scroll up
or uh it's on the back oh okay here you
go um like all the same people that's on
the other one RJ mitt Anna gun Dean
Norris Ray Cruz Charles Baker Matt Jones
Stephen Michael Gaza Louie and Daniel
monata breaking bass Breaking Bad cast
of nine so you get also Jonathan Banks
you can also add Jonathan Banks when's
that
happen
great so if you buy it they'll also you
give it back and and the lelu kids will
get you Jonathan Banks as well well done
thank you 30035 300 305 305 3 305 300
305 305 300 305 305 3 305 3 305 3 305
305 3 305 3 305 going once 300 by 35
hours going twice last
call
sold $300 online $300
online uh Lot number 106 is a sign cast
photo from the movie The Water Boy and
it has uh Kathy Bates Henry Winkler
Peter Dante Allan covert Blake Clark fua
balk Clint Howard and John lockran
everybody but the water boy himself so
you got to provide the Sandler
500 yeah take it away yeah 500 get 505
555 55
555555 55 55 55 5 55 5 55 going once I
got 500 online bid
$55 going twice last
call so $500 online $500 online
Lot number 107 my friends also comes to
us from lelu multiprops it's a cobra Kai
cast signed poster and it has 16 names
Stars man Ralph machio Williams abka
Martin Cove Mary Mouser Jacob Bertrand
Giani denzo denzo Vanessa Rubio pton
list Joe SEO uh Hannah Keele Thomas Ian
Griffith Nicole Brown Analisa Cochran
Ron Thomas Tony Odell and Shan Kanan
that's a lot of [__] signatures uh
the bidding begins that 700 wow 705 700
755 700 705 700 75 5 700 75 700 75 700
75 going once come on ladies gentlemen
700 75 going twice last
call sold 700
[Music]
online that's like and then the rest is
cross all right next up kids uh Lot
number 108 is also a clerk script pack
this one's a little different it has the
US Clerk's Chasing Amy dual screenplay
but it also has the UK clerks screenplay
um never available here in the states
and they're both signed by ears truly I
got 250 but 255 250 255 55 55 55 55 55
255 get 250 get 255 250 255 250 get 255
get 55 get 55 get 250 get 255 get 255
250 get 255 250 get 255 get 250 get 255
250 by 255 going once 250 B
$255 going twice last
call $250 online yes thank you online
mystery bitter uh the next item we have
up a lot 109 is a sealed tesd album
signed by Brian Walt and and Brian Quinn
himself Q um it was the I don't know how
many albums they've done but this is the
first one they did I had two so there's
one here uh up for auction take it away
200 205 200 get 205 get 205 get 200 get
20555 get 205 200 get 205 200 205 200
get 205 200 205 200 get 20555 200 get
205 200 get 205 going once 200 get by
$25 going twice last
call $200
online thank you
onliner moving right along Lot 110 uh we
got a hockey Crest boom box hockey Crest
uh looks like this very plain very
simple that it has got no current bid
let's not do that
40 all right we're at 40 bucks I think
it's neat guys I had one as a kid that's
a nice a boom box yeah I had a boom box
all the time 4 now5 take it from 40
we'll try to get through it fast 40 40
now 5 45 45 45 45 45 40 45 45 50 60 60
70 70 70 70 7 60 7 70 60 7 70 60 7 60 7
60 7 going once $60 $70 going twice last
call $60 right here nice
buy all right yeah we might as well
we'll do one last crust the rest are
crust we're going to leave the crests
they're online right so people keep
bidding on those CR CR online but for
here for in the room the last Crest
we'll do is this uh Supergirl patch
silent Supergirl carrying Kevin Smith
who was the director of few episodes of
the show um and it's at 95 bucks 95 in
100 95 in 100 get to 100 get to 110
100it 105 100 bit 105 105 105 105 105
get 105 get 105 105 105 105 get 105 bit
105 105 100 105 105 105 105 going once
$15 going twice 105 110 110 110 110 115
110 bid 115 15 get about 115 I got 110
bid 115 110 115 115 110 115 110 115 110
115 going once 110 115 hours going twice
last
call sold $110 right up front here
second row second
row um all right so we're gonna online
at the actual auction site the PR are
still up there correct Stephen what's
that can you do3 can we do 113 we can
[__] do anything you want especially
if you ask like that that was awesome
113 the Jurassic
spark yeah maybe um all right where do
we start it how much is it
75 okay 75 and 80 80 but 90 90 90 but 90
but 90 why you keep bidding stop it but
she's 85 90 85
89909 you're 85 in the back bid 90 I got
a 9090 90 get 90 get 90 85 get 90 9090 I
got 85 in the back bid 90 85 get 9090
99990 going once 805 90 going twice last
call sold $85 back there hey well
[Applause]
done um are there any other crests that
people like wait I wanted that
one all of them we'll talk afterwards um
which one 136 136 what was
that is the Charlie Brown one him by
himself done and done uh jump to 136 if
you
can there you are uh he looks small but
he's uh he's the no that's not it he's
by himself no he's I think you wanted
which one did you want by
himself
uh bidding starts at 75 it is a silent
Bop as Charlie
Brown Ernie's got it all right we're
ready yes 75 now 80 75 at 80 80 75 and
80 80 75 and 80 80 75 and 80 75 and 80
75 and 80 75 and 80 75 and 80 going once
$75 and 80 going twice last call sold
$75 nice Buy in the front row
well
done okay 121 121 let's throw up 121
please 121
is oh nothing can kill the
Grimace done and done this one's sign
nothing can kill the Grimace starting at
it's at 90 90 100 100 get to 110 110 12
120 120 13 13 1340 140 150 150 150 160
170 70 180 180 180 180 180 180 180 170
180 180 180 170 180 170 180 180 170 180
180 180 180 170 180 180 170 180 180 180
170 180 170 180 170 180 going
once I got 170 over here bid 180 170 180
180 170 180 going once $1 170 bid $180
going twice last call I'm good sold $170
in the fourth row there excellent job
thank you for your
support totally um what
else 67 was that the Goodwill Hunting
jacket it's sold right the goodwi
hunting jacket we have it we didn't skip
it we put it up there were no bids oh
because there were no bids in the room
somebody interested in it what number is
it 67 throw up 67 we still have it for
sure
yes yeah really should have everybody
tell us what they want just tell me the
name of the movie you want to
see uh there it is so 67 is this what
we're talking about the Goodwill Hunting
carard jaget
500 oh no we're not
haggling
no I I'll sell it at another auction
we'll eventually get 500 500 about 500
this is the time to buy it 500 next time
I'll do 800 I got 500 thank you been 5
and a quarter 5 about 5 and a quarter 5
and a quar 5 and a qu 5 and a quarter I
got 500 get about 525 500 5 25 500 5 25
going once
5525 going twice last call nice buy for
$500 thank you
sir well done look at that late bloomer
man out of nowhere [__] he um what is
it what was 68 let's go back one oh
Hadad
one no I'm gonna hold on to
that it's got bids on
it you put it there I did all right
here's a little backstory on this this
could be the Jersey they almost died in
there were three they were all three XLS
and they're in my closet I forget which
one I wore that night so I'm not saying
this is the one that I definitely had a
heart attack in but it's one of the
three that I possibly did so I'm
actually kind of partial to it but if
yall want to bid on it and they've
already started bidding on it online
$5,000 oh no no no 3,000 2,000 I got 550
but 575 575 about 575 about 5 about 575
5 5 555 555 565 560 rather 560 56 5 5
555 and 560 5 55 560 555 560 56 555 560
550 560 555 get 560 555 get 560 555 get
560 555 bid 560 going once and he just
signed it as well 575 thank you 575 580
580 580 580 I can't go any lower at that
point 580 575 behind me been 580 58 58
you came all this way what's another $30
580 580 580 5 585 585 585 585 585 58 585
58 585 58 5 85 5 5 85 5 8 5 85 going
once 5 8 5 85 going twice and my good to
go I have 580 out there in the audience
mid 585 I got 580 in the Hat mid 585 58
get about 585 get about 58 a 585 going
once you got 600 600
610 610 605 I'll stick to my $5 incents
cuz that's what they're stuck to 605 605
get by 605 I got 600 online bit 605 600
by 605 600 by 605 when are you going to
see another one when's it going to come
up for bid again this is going to go
away in somebody's uh quad is never
going back out
605 oh I have it up 625 630 this's what
happens when you think too long it goes
much higher 6:30 might be 630 sir 630
get by 630 get by 630 get by 625 get by
6 630 625 get by 630 get by 625 get by
630 get by 625 paid
$630 going once 625 by $630 going twice
last call am I good to go sold
$625 online
[Applause]
online uh all right man the last again
we're going to leave the
yes do another Charlie Brown Crest which
one
I think we sold the only solo one but we
have other ones where I'm standing next
to
Jay throw up the what number is that
throw up
134 real quick yeah really make a deal
with this guy holy
[__] um all right let's stop at 128 on
the
way almost there kids 128 closing in on
128 is The Flash
Crest you into
it yeah all right opening bid is 75
bucks $75 75 and 80 808080 75 and 8080
on the flash this time 75 and 80 80 75
and 80 80 75 and 80 75 and 80 75 and 8
7585 obiously but the lightning bolt is
lighting a joint at the bottom 75 at
8080 75 and 80 going once $75 and 80
going twice last call 80 now 5 85 85 now
9090 9090 9090 9090 85 90 yes can't tell
85 90
8599 90 going once 85 90 going twice
let's call 95 95 95 95 95 95 95 9 95 9
95 99 95 going once 90 $95 going twice
last call sold for $90 in the front row
buyer on the front row excellent
job um what was the other uh oh a
Charlie Brown Cris so go forward to like
one
134 there's one hold on so I'll show you
the go
back one more so there's this one
edication that's me and Andy Mish keep
going that's me and Mark Bernard for Fat
Man on Batman keep going me and Ralph
Garmin for Hollywood Babylon and the
next one should be Jay for Jay and S and
Bob get old those the four Charlie Brown
crests that are
left had you be wow what a [__] out
of the-box choice right me and Kaminsky
co-signed that [__] we love Andy
melish all right so it's GNA be Ed [__]
man you ain't bid you gonna buy this
[__] for 75 done man
75 that yes no biding [__] it that
anybody who likes Andy enough to pick
him out of four I'm going to text him
and tell him I'm so excited um and I'm
signing this okay I'm sorry so that's
done yeah we won't auction that one we
sell it to yes well
done um okay any other
crests the giant sbob which
one the get old one absolutely uh go to
two screens up there you go uh it's at
80 according to the internet right now
80 bid 90 80 85 95 95 100 105
105 105 115 115 120 120 120 about 120
about 12 125 125 125 125 125 130 130 130
130 130 130 130 130 130 130 130 130 now
5 135 get about 135 get about 135 now
140 140 140 145 145 now 150 150 155 155
155 155 155 get about 155 get about 155
get about 155 155 get about 155 get
about 155 get about 155 get about 155 go
going once 150 get about 155 going
twice you can bid 155 160 I'm sorry 160
160 I need some kind of momentto for
today 160 we could and I'm a big Charlie
Brown fan so 1505 about 160 but you can
bid against me come on 160 155 get about
160 160 165 170 170 170 170 170 170 170
170 170 170 170 170 165 and 170 175 175
180 180 185 190 19 19 190 190 190 190
190 185 with 190 you all right yeah I'm
okay 185 190 190 185 about 190 going
once $185 about $190 going twice 190 now
200 200 200 about 200 2 and a quarter
two and a qu 225 210 200 21 21 21 21 200
210 going once 200 get by $210 going
twice last call sold two $200 I bought
it thank you right here in the room yeah
well
done and thank you for your smal Cinemas
support uh 142 kids put it up on the
screen it's the Mysterio Crest why are
we doing
this who oh you're right on all right so
it starting at 85 bucks we got 85 now 90
85 get 9090 909090 9085 909090 90 you're
my 85 and 90 oh I had 85 you're right 90
5 9 9 995 99 95 90 9 95 90 90 90 90 90
995 90 B 95 going once I got 90 out here
bid 95 95 95 I got 90 standing bid 95
going
twice thank you 95 bid 100 100 105 105
105 105 105 105 I got 100 standing in
the room B 105 get 105 105 1055 100 105
going once $15 going twice last call 105
online 105 thank you 110 115 110 bit 115
115 115 T 100 T 115 110 B 115 110 bit
115 going once 110 B $115 going twice
last
call yes I have 110 in room I I had to
think about it too sold $110 right here
on the right buyer
number right
there
141 uh pull out thank you the reverse
flash this is why you never take
requests you just I know you sell right
through it that's the best approach but
we can't be like we need help at SM
castle c be like [__] your money like
you know they want to buy Crest we're
here to sell Crest that's right we've
got a double set patch here these these
crests are smaller so this flash Crest
is going to be smaller than the flash
Crest that y'all won um
it's that big flash Crest they shrunk
and did this but it's a two- Pack set
and this is The Flash and again the
lightning bolt lights to joint and then
this is uh the reverse flash 80 bit 90 I
got 80 uh 90 bit 100 now I get 100 100
to 110 100 to 110 110 120 120 120 120
130 130 130 130 130 130 140 140 140 140
140 it's two for one 140 140 get above
140 get above 140 get above 140 what 140
uh 140 uh 135 bid 140 140 140 145 145
145 get about 145 145 about 145 140 get
about 145 get about 145 get about 145
you know tomorrow you're going to go you
know I should just went that extra five
bucks why didn't I just bid five more
dos 145 that's what you're the devil man
140 get about 145 140 about 145 140 145
going once 140 get $145 going twice last
call sold $140 once again on the right
13 119 119 please and and okay 135 and
135 well hold on we're close to 135 so
go to
135 that one the small
popup
yeah let's see it's smaller than the
other one um like about half the size
see it's like miniature
mini I'll sell it to you right now for
for 75
bucks 75
sold I mean
80 um sign it done and done I'm gonna
put it right over one of their faces so
was 75 now 80 now five and it's sold
right $80 yes that's what you did there
you go thank you neighbor give it up for
neighbor man he's always looking out for
us am I tagging these two flashes as
well copy what were the other numbers
kids 14 140 and 119 whatever's closer
let's go to
that love you
too both sign okay which one are we
looking
at who's into this
yeah biddings at 90 bucks I got 90 bit
100 or 95 95 B 100 100 100 get 100 get
100 give 95 100 get 100 get 100 get 95
100 get 100 get 100 get 95 100 get 100
95 100 95 100 95 100 going once 110 115
120 120 120 120 120 120 120 115 bid 120
120 115 bid 120 115 bid 120 get about 12
150 get about 120 going once 115 bid 120
going twice last call I got there yep
sold $15 in the
Hat you want me to tag
it okay next up what was the other
number 119 what do we
got thank
you the clerk storyboard Crest is that
what somebody was interested in bang uh
we are at 100s 105 110 110 110 110 110
105 it 110 105 110 110 110 105 110 going
once 105 $110 going twice last call sold
$105 hour up here excellent job Ryan
Ryan's is literally at every show we do
here man and I'm tagging this as well
what other numbers kids anything else
127 127 it
is and
144 127 is uh another uh t-shirt that I
had done when I directed an episode when
we wrapped and so later on I turned it
into the crest uh it's me as the flash
he's got the backwards baseball cap
clearly has the beard um there it is
it's pretty big too uh 85 bucks 85 bit
90 90 bit5 95 95 100 105 105 105 11010
115 115 115 120 120 120 120 120 It's
Only Money now you bought it add it to
your collection 120 120 125 125 you know
you want it 125 125 125 125 120 125 12
about 125 125 120 about 125 going once
$12 about $125 going twice last
call sold $120 here in the Hat loving it
right here in the house tag this as well
next one is what number 14
144 oh it's the kfs Kevin fuckon Smith I
love
this uh this is a look at that man he
does chicken right
um current bid is 75 bucks take it away
75 80 85 85 85 999 95 95 95 95 get 95
909 been 95 90 been 95 95 105 105 115
115 1 110 110 help you sir 110 110 110
110 I already got 105 110 110 115 120
120 120 120 120 12 120 12 120 120 120
125 125 125 130 130 130 1 30 130 130 130
12 12 get 130 13 130 130 12 get 130 130
your round sir 130 12 130 12 130 130 135
135 140 145 145 145 145 145 150 150 155
155 160 165 165 16 started there's no
friends here 165 hit it again 165 170
175 180 180 185 185 190 190 190 190 190
190 190 190 195 195 200 200 200 200 200
200 200 200 200 205 205 205 200 205 2005
205 going once Finger Licking Good 205
going twice last call so for $200 thank
you guys for bidding thank you both for
bidding you open the bidding [__] sorry
about that um what was the other one man
Martian Manhunter this is the Martian
Manhunter Crest it looks like the thing
that goes across his chest I tagged it
um there it is no current bid who's into
this 50 bucks done and done give it up
for DJ he won all
sold yeah I'll sign it as
well uh any other numbers kids
130 the Holly weed one I got 75 B 80 85
85 85 85 85 85 85 85 85 885 8 85 8 85 8
85 8585 going once 80 85s going twice
last call sold $80 on the left $80 on
the
left
well done oh my God you rock um all
right kids uh Ernie's telling me we got
to wrap up
but and you'll cherish it
right done and done we sold that [__]
Mar give it up for him absolutely it
goes to a good home we're we're
auctioning [__] we're not even [__]
auctioning
man um okay last item we're going to do
before we get out of here kids is uh the
other Bullwinkle that I drew
commemorating tonight's Smokin event
also pict it also comes with a picture
so if you win it I'll take a picture
with you um that one was this way this
one one was horizontal one's vertical so
it's slightly different but it's say SM
in 2024 and signed by your truly at the
bottom for most people who are like why
Bullwinkle it's the only thing I can
draw well you Would Imagine by now I
would have learned to draw Silent Bob
but I didn't uh it's just always
bowinkle so here we go uh let's start
at there we go we're 125 125 about 150
150 150 150 150 now two 175 175 175 175
175 175
2 200 200 175 200 185 help anybody 185
175 and 185 you're my 175 and 185 185
185 175 185 175 180 180 185 185 190 190
190 190 190 190 190 190 190 I did you at
190 I got 185 in 190 190 195 195 195 200
205 215 2 and A4 235 235 235 235 235 get
235 get 300 230 230 I was hoping for 300
235 240 240 245 250 250 250 get 2 2 2 2
2 2 2 250 250 2 2 2 245 bid 250 going
once 245 going by 250 255 255 260 260
260 260 get by 2 2 2 2 260 going once
255 B 260 265 270 270 270 270 270 275
275 280 280 280 It's Only Money Now 280
280 280 275 280 280 285 285 290 295 295
295 300 300 300 300 300 300 300 300 got
295 and 300 300 300 295 and 300 going
once 300 310 oh sniped so 310 get by 310
get by 310 320 320 320 320 320 320 320
320 320 320 3 by 320 3 by 320 by 320 320
going once 3 $320 going twice last
call 330 340 340 340 340 340 don't let
them have it come on hit it again 340
330 get about 340 get about 330 get
about 340 get about 330 get about 340 34
335 335 340 340 you started it 340 340
get about 340 get about 340 get about
340 get about 340 going once is it down
is it down to two yeah I got got 335
here been 340 340 get about 340 get
about 340 going once 340 going
twice I was just going to say I could
draw another one and then they could
both be happy and [__] sh don't tell
them
that yes let's let's do this let's so
what is it up to I'm at 335 right here
so let's do would you both do
300 well I know you would who is he
bidding
against would you do 300 done let's just
to two for
300 a hold on all right hold on so what
he's saying is instead of he'll he'll
you 300 for one he'll draw you a new one
at $300 so there'll be two and the man
back there he'll draw yeah let's close
it cuz I can't keep drawing all right so
that's two extra draws so is everybody
cool 300 where is it up front here sold
right here sold right there and it was
whoever yelled over in this area it was
over there sold in the back so he'll
draw you once they'll have them for you
by next year no problem two canvases
coming beautiful so I'll draw them
before we get out of here next year um
no I'll do it live on stage uh kids
that's literally everything that we have
to auction with the exception of some
crests that are available online for the
folks that are playing along and stuff
like that I can't believe we got through
all that merchandise and more
importantly I can't believe yall gave so
generously both here in the room and
online I can't thank you uh enough man
please uh give yourselves a round of
applause you helping us save SM Castle
means the world man um give it up for
the two guys who made the event happen
you got Stephen and you got Ernie give
it up for
them give up for red who was displaying
our stuff give it up for Connor who took
your [__] money and
[__] but give it up for the real well
give it up for the staff of course my
cin cous they've been taking care of you
all day but the true magic of the room
ladies and gentlemen the reason y'all
came and what you'll be thinking about
like you go to sleep tonight you'll be
like three going to 25 25 give it up for
the voice himself The Velvet tongue Joe
bner ladies and
gentlemen uh thank you if you came here
to play thank you if you're playing
along at home uh there's a grand total
that we'll put out when we're all done
and stuff like we'll announce what the
grand total was but we can't thank you
enough um this is the movie theater that
I grew up going to the movies at when I
was a kid keeping it alive mean
something to me my father took me here
man my father father ain't around
anymore he's been dead for 20 years but
I know he was in this building so every
time I sit in a theater seat here it's
like he's there kind of next to me so
aside from keeping it open for the
community because this is the movie
theater that birthed my interest in
movies I would like to keep it open for
others man maybe there are other future
Kevin Smiths God [__] forbid who like
movies enough to like make it their
Pursuit and life and stuff so aside from
like it being uh something we do that we
enjoy doing because it's fun we do it
for the community because the community
really seems to appreciate this great
town of Atlantic Highlands New Jersey
but selfishly kids at the end of the day
I keep this place open because my father
was here once many times when I was a
kid so keeping it alive means a lot to
me and to my mom at home who has been
watching the whole [__]
time
Mom thank you for being here don't
forget man we got some screenings coming
up Zach amir's happening tonight we've
got clerks open all night happening on
the 20th that's us showing all three
clerks movies all night long we got the
same day Space Balls is happening next
day Batman Returns uh always something
fun happening here at SM Castle Cinemas
and that's because yall took the time to
help and support us today I thank you
all so very much man this is our
Cathedral Kids film is our religion and
SM Castle Cinema is is our Cathedral
thank I'll take that [__] right there
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
man have a great night be careful going
home I'll see you later
[Applause]
on
all